ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके ओके सो वी आर लाइव
नाउ लेट म चेक
वनस चलिए मैं चेक कर लेता हूं एक बार मेरे
साइड से
भी तो मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी से आप लोग आर
वी लाइव
गाइस लाइव हम आ चुके हैं
क्या ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है जस्ट
वेट हां जी तो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव चलिए
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको हेलो हेलो
हेलो सबको भाई सबको गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
नमस्ते क्या हाल चाल है भाई
सबके क्या हाल है सबके बढ़िया
आवाज जा रही है मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ
परफेक्ट है ना बिल्कुल एकदम
चकाचक सब कुछ बढ़िया ना ऑडियो
वीडियो चलिए ओके बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
वेरी गुड वेरी गुड बहुत गजब
बढ़िया हां जी तो भाई लोग आज हम क्या करने
वाले हैं आज बहुत ही शानदार टॉपिक मैं ले
कर आया हूं आपको काफी मजा आएगा आज की
क्लास में अगेन जहां पर हम लो हैंगिंग
फ्रूट्स को फाइंड करने वाले हैं बट उसके
पहले कुछ चीजें हैं जो मैं आपको जरूर
बताना चाहूंगा ठीक
है ओके तो पहले आ जाने देते सबको एक बार
जवाइन कर लेते एक बार सब
लोग मैं भी बढ़िया मैं भी बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया
ओके
ओके ओके ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट हां जीी
भैया सबको नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग सबको चलिए तो
आज की जो टॉपिक है वह बहुत शानदार होगी बट
मैं यहां पर क्या है कि वेट कर रहा हूं और
लोगों को जवाइन करने का क्योंकि मैंने
आपको बोला पर कि आज अगर एटलीस्ट 100 लोग
नहीं होंगे तो फिर जब आप मेरी एक्सपेक्ट
पेशंस को फुलफिल नहीं कर पा रहे हो तो
मेरे को भी थोड़ा प्रॉब्लम है सीधी सी बात
है आप अगर सीरियस नहीं हो तो मैं भी शायद
उतना ना रहूं तो मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि आप लोग अपने दोस्तों को बोलिए
या र आप है तो प्लीज जवाइन कीजिए लाइव
सेशन क्योंकि लाइव सेशन में आप आते हैं तो
आपको ही बेनिफिट होता है ठीक
है ओके आई विल बी
वेटिंग
चलिए मैं स्टार्ट अभी कर वेट
करूंगा जो क्लास है उसको स्टार्ट करेंगे
बट थोड़ी देर में करेंगे जब तक यहां पर
100 लोग नहीं आ जाते हैं ठीक है सबको
नमस्ते एसके इंजेक्शन कब आएगा एस इंजेक्शन
में टाइम लगेगा आने में अभी तो यार एस
इंजेक्शन वो तो क्रिटिकल वन बिलिटी में आ
गई ना तो उसमें तो थोड़ा टाइम लग जाएगा ना
तो थोड़ा वेट कीजिए एशन में चलिए
और तब तक मैं आपको बता देता हूं यह हमारी
बेसिकली
linkedin.in पे पोस्ट कीजिए
पे जब आप पोस्ट करें तो हमारे इस पेज को
टैग किया कीजिए ठीक है उसके बाद हमारी ये
[संगीत]
twitter.com साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी
कोर्स जो हमारी डीसी जेएसपी कोर्स है
बेसिकली यह एक एथिकल हैकिंग की कंप्लीट ए
टू जेड कोर्स है आप इसको इनरोल कर सकते
हैं एथिकल हैकिंग सीखने के लिए अगर आपको
बिल्कुल आईडिया नहीं है तो साथ में बग
बाउटी की आप प्लेलिस्ट फॉलो कर ही रहे हैं
दैट्ची हा
चलिए
अ सर बिजनेस लॉजिक लेबिलिटी मिली है बट
रिपोर्ट ऑप्शन नहीं थे उससे साइट पे ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं अगर नहीं थे तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई इश्यूज नहीं है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है हेलो
हेलो नहीं बट ठीक है ना बट इतने लोग हैं
00 से ऊपर लोग हैं और यहां 100 लोग भी
नहीं आते हैं तो ये तो गलत चीज है ना यार
इट्स अ वेरी रॉन्ग थिंग आप खुद सोचो ना है
ना चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं थोड़ी देर
में और भी लोगों को आने देते हैं और आपको
आज जो मैं वलने बिलिटी के बारे में बताने
वाला हूं जिस बग के बारे में हम डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं देखने वाले हैं एंड उसको
समझने वाले हैं उसको मैंने नाम दिया है लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स अब ये लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स
क्या है इसका मतलब क्या है ये कोई बग लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स कोई बग नहीं है ठीक है
सीधी सी बात है यह कोई वनबिल नहीं है इसके
अंदर बहुत सारे मल्टीपल वनबिल आती है बग्स
आती है जिसको आप लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स की
कैटेगरी में डाल सकते हो इसका मतलब है ऐसे
वने बिलिटी जो बहुत इजी टू फाइंड होते हैं
और एक बार में आप एक से ज्यादा फाइंड कर
सकते हैं किसी एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट पे एक
किसी पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम पे ठीक है अब
इसमें बहुत तरह-तरह के वलने बिलिटी को आप
इंक्लूड कर सकते हैं अपने अकॉर्डिंग जैसे
कि आप ब्रोकेन लिंक हाईजैकिंग
इसको आप इंक्लूड कर सकते हैं इसके अंदर
में उसके बाद आप इसी के अंदर में यू कैन
इंक्लूड
मिसिंग एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड उसके बाद आप ओरिजिन आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर को भी डाल सकते हैं इसको भी आप
डाल सकते हो ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर को यह
भी एक लेबिलिटी है जो आप कंसीडर कर सकते
हैं काइंड ऑफ ठीक है और इसको मैं यहां पे
इसको इधर कर देते हैं हां ठीक
है सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी इसके बाद आप इसमें डाल
सकते हैं सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
एक्सपायरिंग
आफ्टर लॉग आउट यह भी आप डाल सकते हैं इसके
बाद आप लॉन्ग
पासवर्ड डॉ अटैक भी डाल सकते हैं एंड
प्लेन एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन को भी आप इसमें
डाल सकते हैं अगर आप चाहे तो डाल सकते हैं
अरवाज एटील इंजेक्शन को आप अलग से भी कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि चेन होके यह और भी बहुत
कुछ करता है तो फिलहाल रह देते इतना एक तो
तीन चार पाच
है पांच को यहां पे रख दिया और भी बहुत
सारे हैं वैराइटीज है थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा मैंने आपको बारबार बोला हुआ है ना
कि बग बाउंटीज में मैंने आपको हमेशा बोला
हुआ है सबको बोला हुआ है बग बाउंट का मतलब
क्या होता है बग बाउंटीज का मतलब होता है
कि ट्राई ट्राई ट्राई प्रैक्टिस प्रैक्टिस
प्रैक्टिस जितना ट्राई करोगे जितनी
प्रैक्टिस करोगे उतना ज्यादा आपके लिए
बेटर होता जाएगा आपका बग बाउंट में काफी
अच्छा होता जाएगा बस इतना मुझे पता है
जितना खुद से एक्सप्लोर करोगे मैं जितना
बता रहा हूं उसके अलावा बहुत कुछ एजिस्ट
करता है इन फैक्ट है यह आप उसको एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए अब मैंने आपको पांच चीजें बता दी
आपको पांच चीजें और एक्स्ट्रा एक्सप्लोर
करना है आपको मैंने टूल को ही बताया आपको
पांच और टूल को एक्सप्लोर करना है ठीक है
तो ये सब जिम्मेदारी आपकी होनी चाहिए
जितना आप एक्सप्लोर करेंगे उतना आप बाकी
लोगों से डिफरेंट हट के रहेंगे जैसे आपकी
मेथड थोड़ी डिफरेंट होगी आपके डुप्लीकेट्स
मिलने के चांसेस कम रहेंगे एंड यू विल बी
रॉकिंग एक्चुअली आपका आ जाएगा आपको बग
बाउटी में जब आपको वैलिड बग्स मिलने
स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे ठीक
है एंड पेन टेस्टिंग का कोर्स कब स्टार्ट
होगा होगा भाई
होगा जल्दी होगा एंड्राइड पन टेस्टिंग का
भी कोर्स जल्दी स्टार्ट होगा ठीक
है सर जी आम मोहम्मद कासिम ओके कासिम
वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम
ब्रदर ठीक है जय हिंद जय हिंद भाई जय
हिंद फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव जवाइन कर रहा हूं
अरे यार फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव जॉइन हो क्या
बात है हां और लाइक ठोका कि नहीं सबने
लाइक ठोका लाइक ठोके कि नहीं ठोके पहले ये
बता दो लाइक ठोक देना यार लाइक ठोकना बहुत
जरूरी है कुछ हो ना हो लाइक जरूर ठोकना है
ठीक है बहुत ज्यादा ठोक लाइक वो करना है
और एक चीज और मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं
गाइ जैसे हमारी जो वेबसाइट है de.com
बेसिकली तो आपको इसी वेबसाइट पे हमेशा
अपडेट रखना है बुकमार्क आप कर लीजिएगा
यहां से जैसे बुकमार्क ऑप्शन है और यहां
पे आप आके आपको जो भी रिकॉर्डेड कोर्सेस
है ना वो आपको यहां मिल जाएंगे अभी हमारे
पास बस python3 हैकिंग यहां पे रिकॉर्डेड
कोर्स डली हुई है अभी कुछ ही टाइम में
हमारी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी अ
थ्र मंथ्स की उसके बाद हमें डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक का सेकंड बैच स्टार्ट होने वाला
है देन डिजिटल देन साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन का एक बैच स्टार्ट होने
वाला है तो जो भी अपकमिंग डिटेल्स है वो
यहां आपको मिल जाएंगी एंड आपको और भी जो
भी हमारी कंपनी से रिलेटेड चीजें यहां पर
आपको अवेलेबल हो जाती है ठीक है तो
रोनिक्स वेबसाइट प विजिट करते रहिएगा चलिए
तो आज की लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स का मतलब क्या
हो जाता है एनी वनबिल एनी वनबिल ट इज
क्वाइट इजी टू
फाइंड काफी इजी होता है जिसको फाइंड करना
जनरली बाकी वले एबिलिटीज के रिस्पेक्ट में
उनको हम लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स के कैटेगरी
में डाल देते हैं ठीक है अब जो नए बग
बाउंट हंटर्स होते हैं जो बिगिनर्स होते
हैं ना दे ऑलवेज ट्राई एंड गो फॉर लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स क्योंकि उनको ना बहुत
इजली वो मिल जाता है लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स
और उनको एक थोड़ा सा लाइक काइंड ऑफ की
उनको एक मोटिवेशन मिल जाती है जैसे उनको
वैलिड बग मिलता है ना दे गेट मोटिवेटेड
आउट ऑफ दैट एंड उस मोटिवेशन में दे
स्टार्ट हंटिंग दे कीप ऑन हंटिंग दे नेवर
लूज मोटिवेशन एंड उनको काफी अच्छा बग
बाउटी में पकड़ उनकी काफी अच्छी हो जाती
है एंड आगे चलके दे डू ग्रेट थिंग्स ओके
और सबसे पहले हम यहां पे जो वल्नरेबल को
देखने वाले हैं दैट वल्नरेबल इज ब्रोकन
लिंक हाईजैकिंग अब ये बहुत ही शानदार
वनबिल है है बहुत ही छोटा सा अब देखो जो
लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स है ना इनके पर आपको
बाउंटीज मिलेंगे तब या हॉल ऑफ फेम या
रिवॉर्ड जब यह आउट ऑफ स्कोप में नहीं
होंगे बहुत सारे लोग हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स
वनबिल को बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स क्या करते
हैं आउट ऑफ स्कोप में डाल देते हैं और
बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम नहीं डालते हैं तो
आपको वैसे प्रोग्राम को सर्च करना है
जिसके आउट ऑफ स्कोप में ये चीज ना हो दिस
इज नॉट इन द आउट ऑफ स्कोप ऑफ एनी
प्रोग्राम तो आपको जब प्रोग्राम पे हंट
करने जाते हो ना जिस किसी भी प्रोग्राम पे
ठीक है हंट करने जाते हो तो आपको वहां पे
चेक करना है उनका इन स्कोप एंड आउट ऑफ
स्कोप आइटम ये चेक करना बहुत जरूरी होता
है जैसे आप ब क्राउड पे गए आप किसी
प्रोग्राम को सर्च कर रहे हो जैसे मैंने
यहां पे एक सर्च किया एक्सो एक्सो स्केल
ठीक है ये प्रोग्राम है मैं इस पे आया ये
एक यूरोपियन क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर्स हैं मैं
यहां पे स्कोप एंड रिवार्ड्स में जाऊंगा
तो मैं इनका पहले स्कोप में देखूंगा कि
इनका स्कोप में क्या है फोकस एरिया आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे एंड फिर आउट ऑफ स्कोप
क्या है तो आप देख सकते हैं आउट ऑफ स्कोप
में यहां पे कस्टमर इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर इज
आउट ऑफ स्कोप फेलियर टू इनवैलिडेट सेशन
इश्यूज ये भी आउट ऑफ स्कोप है मतलब
इनवैलिडेट सेशन इशू जबकि इसमें एक आपका
वने बिलिटी है सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग आफ्टर
लॉग आउट तो काइंड ऑफ यह रिजेक्ट कर देंगे
इस टाइप की व बिलिटी को बट कई लोग नहीं
करते हैं कई लोग इसको इंक्लूड करके रखते
हैं तो आप उन पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट्स एंड प्रोग्राम्स को चूज कर सकते
हो एंड ये व बिलिटी बिल्कुल फाइंड कर सकते
हो एंड यू विल गेट द बाउंट आल्सो बाउंट जो
है रेंज करेगी इस कैटेगरी के लिए
जनरली $50 टू $ ठीक है $200 एंड ये डिपेंड
करता है सीवियरिंग के ऊपर क्या सीवियरिंग
आप उस पर्टिकुलर इन पर्टिकुलर लेबिलिटी से
दिखा पा रहे हो कई बार क्या होता है कि
जैसे ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर लेबिलिटी
आपको मिली अब इसका यूज करके आपने
अनरिस्पांसिव कर दिया एप्लीकेशन लेवल ऑफ
डॉस अटैक कर दिया अनरिस्पांसिव कर दिया
किसी पर्टिकुलर वेब एप्लीकेशन को या इसका
यूज करके आपने एक्सेसेस फाइंड कर लिया
पर्टिकुलर एक टारगेट के ऊपर में तो आपका
यह जो है ना ये काफी एक चेन अप हो जाता है
वनबिल एंड वो हाई सीवियरिंग में चली जाती
है एंड आपको ज्यादा बाउंट भी मिल सकती है
00000 000 डिपेंड करता है इंपैक्ट के ऊपर
बग बाउंटीज के अंदर में जितना बड़ा
इंपैक्ट होगा किसी वनबिल का उतनी बाउंट
मिलेगी याद रखिएगा दो बग
बाउंटीज की एक बंदे का अगर इंपैक्ट ज्यादा
है तो उसको सेम बग के लिए ज्यादा बाउंट
मिलेगी दूसरे का इंपैक्ट कम शो कर पा रहा
है अगर तो उसको कम बाउंट मिलेगी तो घबराना
बिल्कुल नहीं है अगर आपको कम बाउंट मिल
रही है समझ जाइए कि वहां पर आपकी इंपैक्ट
कम है उसके बाद नो रेट लिमिट न फॉर्म
इश्यूज वल बिलिटी दैट ओनली रिजल्ट्स इन इन
इनकंसीक्वेंशियल लॉसेस टू एसो स्केल ठीक
है ऑल पी फ सिरिटी वनबिल एज डिस्क्राइब ऑन
द बक क्राउड वलने बिलिटी टैक्सनॉमी ये आप
देख लीजिएगा वर्क क्राउड का जो पी फ क्या
होता है एक्टिविटीज अकाउंटिंग टू डिनायल
ऑफ अमाउंटिंग टू डिनायल ऑफ सर्विसेस
मिसिंग सिक्योर ये ठीक है ईमेल स्पूफिंग
ठीक है ये ईमेल स्पूफिंग टू इनबॉक्स ड्यू
टू मिसिंग और
कॉन्फिडो ऑन ईमेल डोमेन ये भी एक है बट
इसको आप थोड़ा चेन अप कर सकते हो मास ईमेल
अटैक के फॉर्म में इसको लाके आप इसको
दिखाओगे अगर जिससे कि उनको लॉस है तो आपका
ये कंसीडर हो सकता है कई केसेस में बट
मोस्टली ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप हो जाते हैं
लेबिलिटी ओनली अफेक्टिंग यूजर्स ऑफ
आउटडेटेड और अन पैस्ड ब्राउजर्स सॉफ्टवेयर
वर्जन डिस्क्लोजर नॉट कंसीडरेबल वेरी
रिसेंट पब्लिक वनबिल पैच अवेलेबल फॉर लेस
दन टू वीक्स अटैक्स दैट रिक्वायर अलाली
यूजर इंटरेक्शन तो इस तरीके से आपको आउट
ऑफ स्कोप चीजों को पढ़ना पड़ेगा नहीं
पढ़ोगे कोई फायदा नहीं है ठीक है रिपोर्ट
करोगे टाइम दोगे हंट करोगे एंड आपको एट
लास्ट कुछ नहीं मिलेगा
राइट अब तो अब तो आपको पता ही है कि
डेविन डेविन एक एआई आ चुका है आप में से
कितनों को पता है डेविन एआई के बारे
में डेविन एआई के बारे में पता है आप
लोगों को
हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू
नो लेट मी नो
गाइस पी फ बक क्राउड पर तीन बार मिला है
एज इंफॉर्मेशन बहुत बढ़िया कांग्रेचुलेशन
बहुत बड़ी बात है य छोटी बात नहीं
है अच्छा यस सर ओके पता है पता है काफी
लोगों को पता है राइट ग्रेट या सो डे एआई
जो है वो काफी खतरनाक एआई एक कभी निकल के
आया है डेविन एआई अगर बात करते हैं तो बाय
अ कॉग्निशन लैब्स इन्होंने डेवलप किया ये
एक फर्स्ट सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर लैब है
सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर एक सॉरी एक एआई है
सॉफ्टवेयर जो कि एआई है जो कि सॉफ्टवेयर
इंजीनियर का काम करेगा हर एक कोड को
लिखेगा डीबगिंग करेगा टेस्ट करेगा
डिप्लॉयड जो एक रियल सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर
करता है एंड सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर्स के लिए
डेवलपर्स के लिए यह बहुत ही डेंजरस प्रूफ
हो सकता है अपकमिंग फ्यूचर में इसका
इंपैक्ट अभी किसी को नहीं पता है फ्यूचर
में क्या किसी को नहीं पता है बट एज फार
एज आई कंसीडर द ग्रोथ एंड पोटेंशियल ऑफ
आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस एंड जीपीटी जीपीटी
अ जो आपने देखा जीपीटी 34 के साथ कितना
स्केल अप हुआ कितना फास्ट ग्रो हुआ तो अगर
उसी स्केल या उससे ज्यादा अ फास्ट अगर यह
स्केल अप हो जाता है तो आने वाले कुछ
सालों में ऐसा हो सकता है कि जहां 10
सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर की जरूरत है वहां
सिर्फ एक सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर की जरूरत
होगी बाकी नौ लोगों को फायर कर दिया जाएगा
यानी कि सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर जो है उसके लिए
भी यह बहुत डेंजरस एआई होने वाला है आने
वाले टाइम में ठीक है मतलब फुल्ली ऑटोनोमस
एआई सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर है आपको कुछ नहीं
करने देगा आपको कुछ नहीं करना सारा काम
आपका यह करेगा सो दिस इज रियली सीरियस
थिंग एंड आई डोंट नो व्हाट इज गोइंग टू
हैपन इन द फ्यूचर ठीक है एआई को लेके
चलिए
अब आ जाते हैं हमारे पहले वलने बिलिटी
ब्रोकेन लिंक हाईजैकिंग इसके बारे में अब
आज जो वने बिलिटी के बारे में बताऊंगा आप
उसको ध्यान दीजिएगा और इसको एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा जब क्लास हो जाएगी आप इसको
प्रैक्टिस कीजिए जितना प्रैक्टिस कीजिए
छोटी-छोटी
जो आपकी छोटी-छोटी प्रोग्राम्स पर ट्राई
कीजिए अब इसको ना आप अय ब्रोकन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग को आप बड़े प्रोग्राम्स प
ज्यादा जल्दी अभी ट्राई मत करना जनरली
आपको कुछ नहीं मिलेगा जो मान लो ग डॉक से
कोई आपको टारगेट मिला है वहां जाइए बक
बहुत ओल्ड कोई प्रोग्राम है बहुत छोटा
मोटा प्रोग्राम है उसपे जाइए हैकर वन पे
कोई है नॉन मैनेज्ड प्रोग्राम है बाय हैकर
वन उसपे जाइए एंड ट्राई कीजिए ये फाइंड
करने का यू विल डेफिनेटली गेट ठीक है मुझे
ऐसा लगता है चलिए ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग
में होता क्या है मैं आपको ये दिखा देता
हूं चलिए ओके अब मान लो लेट्स सपोज ठीक है
मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं मैं अपनी
वेबसाइट प चलता
हूं difference.com पे ठीक है मैं यहां पे
आया यह टारगेट है मान लो फिलहाल के लिए
ऐसे ही अभी तुम लोग कोई और टारगेट रख लेना
अब मैं इसके हर एक पेज को एक्सप्लोर करके
चेक करूंगा कहां पे लिंक है कोई लिंक लिंक
कहां है कोई यह मुझे देखना है जो क्लिके
बल लिंक होती है जो कहीं पर हमें
रीडायरेक्ट करता हो सिंपल तो जैसे कि मेरा
यहां सोशल मीडिया है यहां पे जो है यहां
सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स है तो सोशल मीडिया
हैंडल्स प जब मैं यहां पर माउस का कसर ले
जाऊंगा य एफ पे तो नीचे में आपको दिखेगा
यहां पर नीचे में बट लेफ्ट में देखो यह
कहां पर लेकर जाएगा हमें
https.com शायद यह आपको दिख नहीं रहा होगा
ड्यू टू द नीचे जो पट्टी है यहां पे उसके
कारण से बट यह हमें कहां लेके जाएगा
facebook.com प ले जाएगा तो मैं अगर इस पर
क्लिक करूंगा तो यह हमें कहां प लेकर जा
रहा है facebook.com पे एंड यहां पे
एक्चुअल एक पेज एजिस्ट करती है जो फ्रक्स
की ही पेज है अब देखो अब यह ब्रोकन अगर
लिंक हाईजैकिंग वने बिलिटी होगी तो मेरा
मान लो यहां यह लिंक मैंने डाला हुआ है
f.com ठीक है यह डाला हुआ है अब मान लो
मैंने यह लिंक ना डाल के मैंने एक लिंक
डाला होता कुछ भी फनि आ कुछ भी लगा दो ऐसा
लिंक डाला होता मैंने अपनी वेबसाइट प
डेनिक्स एक्स आर एस एफ एस डीजी ऐसा कुछ
लिंक डाला होता यहां प फुक वाले बटन पे अब
मैं इसको ओपन करता तो क्या खुलता यह वाली
चीज खुलती अब मैं इसको एंटर करता तो एंटर
जब करता ना तो ये आ रहा है दिस कंटेंट इज
नॉट अवेलेबल एट द मोमेंट मतलब इस इस
पर्टिकुलर यूजर नेम से कोई पेज ही नहीं है
अब अटैकर क्या करेगा इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर
नेम का यह वाला जो यूजर नेम मैंने यहां पर
दिया यह
वाली अब इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर नेम का एक
वो मेरे ओरिजिनल
एंड क्या होता है कि वो अपडेट करना भूल
जाते हैं या छोड़ देते हैं उतना माइंड वो
नहीं करते भूल जाते हैं या जस्ट रह जाता
है तो उस केस में यहां पे ब्रोकन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग हो जाती है एंड यहां पे जब वो
बंदा कोई अटैकर ने चेंज कर दिया है तो अब
जो बंदे आएंगे यहां पे ये एक फेक पेज होगा
ओबवियसली तो आइडेंटिटी इश्यूज आ जाएंगे
यहां पे क्रेडिबिलिटी इशू आएगा इस कंपनी
के लिए ट्रस्ट इश्यूज आ जाएंगे जो भी इसके
क्लाइंट है या जो भी इसके विजिटर्स हैं
मेंबर्स हैं उनके लिए तो यह कंपनी के लिए
एक लॉस होता है यह एक अ ट्रस्ट लॉस हो गया
एक अ किसी भी कंपनी के लिए क्रेडिबिलिटी
की लॉस हुई यहां पे तो इसके लिए कंपनी
आपको पे भी करती है कि चलो भई अगर हमें
कोई लॉस है तो भाई यह तो फिर पेबल है
लेकिन अब यह भी हो सकता है दिस माइट बी
हैपन अब यह सोचो खुद एक इमेजिन करो कि
मैंने यहां पे फेक
पे रीडायरेक्ट कर दी थी यहां पे यहां पे
एक फेक पेज होता और उस
instagram2 में हकर बना देंगे अब ये देख
के कोई भी लगता है यार ये तो जेनुइन पेज
है क्योंकि हम तो इनकी वेबसाइट से आए हैं
और 00 में वो पे भी कर देगा और उसको बदले
में कुछ नहीं मिला लेट्स सपोज तो ये स्कैम
कर दिया उन्होंने हमारी क्रेडिबिलिटी का
यूज करके हमारी ट्रस्ट का यूज करके सो दिस
इज वेरी डेंजरस फॉर अ कंपनी उनका ट्रस्ट
फैक्टर के ट्रस्ट फैक्टर क्रेडिबिलिटी
फैक्टर इनकी वजह से तो यह है ब्रोकन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग बहुत ही सिंपल सा वने बिलिटी है
बट इसका यूज जो है ना इसका यूज वो बहुत
ज्यादा प्रॉब्लेम हो सकता है बहुत ज्यादा
प्रॉब्लेम ठीक है किसी भी कंपनी के लिए
समझ में आ रहा है आप लोगों को ये आप लोगों
को समझ में आ रहा
है आप लोग बताइए
प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी
नो आर यू गेटिंग
प्लीज रेस्पों
गाइस चलिए तो अब आपका काम क्या है आपको
समझ में आ गया ना अब आपका क्या काम है
यहां पर आपको समझ में आ गया होगा जैसे कोई
भी एक प्रोग्राम कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम को
चूज कर लीजिए ठीक
है
ओके कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम कुछ चूज कर लीजिए
किसी भी जगह से चूज कर लीजिए लाइक बक राउट
से कर लीजिए हैकर वन प चलते
हैं मैं यहां पे लॉगइन कर लेता
हूं ओके सो यहां पे ठीक
है डायरेक्टरी प चलते हैं कोई भी एक
प्रोग्राम को यहां से चूज कीजिए या आपके
बक राउड प्लेटफॉर्म से चूज कर लीजिए
डिपेंड करता है आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
एंड उसको एक्सप्लोर करना शुरू कर दए अब
जैसे एगो स्केल है ठीक है भैया अब ये एजो
स्केल में ना ऐसा कोई ब्रोकेन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग का कुछ आउट ऑफ स्कोप में मेंशन
नहीं है तो इसका मतलब दे विल एक्सेप्ट इट
अगर आपने इनको रिपोर्ट किया तो सिंपल सा
चीज है तो या तो इंफॉर्मेशन कर दे कोई बात
नहीं बट एक्सेप्ट तो करेंगे तो यहां पे
अभी इनका कोई वेबसाइट है क्या वेब पोर्टल
है इनका वेबसाइट टेस्टिंग है यहां पे वेब
पोर्टल इनका ओबवियसली यहां पे ये अ है
यहां पे तो ये पल ड एको स्केल पे जाता है
यहां यहां पे सो दिस वन अब जैसे यहां पे
आई फॉरगॉट माय पासवर्ड है तो यह कहां पे
फॉरगॉट पे जाता है ठीक है एंड आई डोंट हैव
एन अकाउंट तो इस पे चले जाते हैं फॉरगेट
में पासवड चलते हैं क्या है देख लेते हैं
ना देखने में कुछ नहीं जाता यहां पे
एस्केल कॉ पे डायरेक्ट चलते
हैं चलिए तो हम यहां पे आ चुके हैं एंड
यहां पे हमने कुछ क्या किया रजिस्टर का
ऑप्शन आ रहा है यहां पे रिसेट पासवर्ड का
ऑप्शन आ रहा है चलिए यहां पे हमारे किसी
काम का कुछ नहीं है यहां पे यहां पे कोई
और लिंक्स है नहीं आपको लिंक्स खोजने हैं
तो ये तो मैनुअल अप्रोच हो गया मैं इसका
ऑटोमेटेड अप्रोच भी आपको बताऊंगा ठीक है
तो ये आ गई अब चलो यहां पे देखो हर जगह
बटंस को खोजो कहां पे लिंक्स हैं वो कहां
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहे हैं वो खोजो चलो ठीक है
तो अब देखते हैं यहां पे जैसे लॉगइन
रजिस्टर कुछ है नहीं ब्लॉग ब्लॉग वाले
सेक्शन को चल लेते हैं पार्टनर प्रोग्राम
में कुछ होगा नहीं अकेडमी पे चल जाते हैं
कांटेक्ट अस पे चल लेते हैं ठीक है नीचे
आते हैं यहां पे नीचे देयर इज नथिंग नथिंग
फुटर में मोस्टली फुटर में आपको बहुत कुछ
मिल जाता है तो फुटर में आ जाते हैं यहां
पे एंड देखो यहां पे में क्या है
ले जाते हो ना तो नीचे में बॉटम में लेफ्ट
में आपको दिख जाता है वो कि कहां पर
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है ये ठीक
[संगीत]
है आवाज बहुत स्लो है नहीं यार आवाज कैसे
स्लो हो सकती है इंपॉसिबल मैं एकदम माइक
को यार मुंह के पास रख के बोल रहा हूं
तुम्हारे साइड यार फोन की प्रॉब्लम होती
है कई लोगों की मैंने देखा है कि या तो या
तो लोकैलिटी के इशू थोड़ा बहुत थोड़ा नॉइस
ज्यादा होता है वॉल्यूम फुल करके सुनना
पड़ता है लेकिन देखता आवाज अभी भी कम है
क्या वॉल्यूम तो सही है यार मेरे साइड
से चलिए तो हम कहां पे थे
हां अब यहां आते हैं जॉब्स वाली जो जॉब्स
पे कर रही है कंपनी कंपनी ठीक है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है अकेडमी वाली अकेडमी पे कर
रही है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है पार्टनर
प्रोग्राम इस पे करही कांटेक्ट तो हम उसपे
जाएंगे सीडीएन सीडीएन पे क्या है सीडीएन
पे कर रही है यहां पे ओके ओके ओके बाकी
चीजें नहीं स्टेटस ठीक है देर इज नथिंग
हियर एब्यूज वाली एब्यूज पे कर रही है
यहां पे सपोर्ट सपोर्ट पे कर रही है चेंज
लो ओपन ओके एपीआई पे चलते हैं
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन पे चलते हैं ओपन सोर्स पे
चलते हैं बैकअप पे चलते हैं सिक्योरिटी प
चलते हैं कंप्लायंस प चलते हैं एफ क प
चलते हैं इन सब को ओपन कर लेते हैं इनके
अंदर कुछ मिल जाए शायद ठीक है तो अब यहां
पे आ गए हम अब यहां पर हम देखते हैं यहां
पे क्या कुछ मिल सकता है कुछ देखने को
मिलेगा ओपन एपीआई लेट्स एक्सप्लोर इट और इ
देयर ओके तो यहां मिला हमें ओपन एपीआई का
ओके ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या मिल रहा है
यह कौन सी पेज है ओके एक्सेसिबल पेज है यह
जेसन है वाईएमएल फम फर्मेट है यह थर्ड
पार्टी के ऊपर जा रही है यह लिंक्स तो तो
हम और भी यहां पे एक्सप्लोर करेंगे इसको
क्रिएट अ सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप तो इसको देखते
हैं क्या ये कहां पे लेके जाता है दिस इज
गोइंग टू अ थर्ड लिंक थर्ड पार्टी लिंक
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है एचएमएससी ये कहां लेकर
जाता है विकपीडिया पे लेके जा रहा है एंड
यहां पे गिट हप ये गिट हब पे लेके जा रहा
है जो कि जा रहा है एगो स्केल इस पे तो
मैं इस पे चलता हूं देखता हूं क्या है
यहां पे जी हां यहां पे है ये गट अब
एजिस्ट करता है अगर मान लो देखो अब ये
क्या होता है ना देखो यहीं पे वनबिल जो है
वो आपको समझनी है कि एक्चुअली वनबिल क्या
है अब जैसे यह इस पे लिंक पे क्लिक करोगे
तो तुम रीडायरेक्ट हो रहे हो ना भाई
रीडायरेक्ट कहां हो रहे हो गिट पेज पे हो
रहे हो अगर यहां पे ये पेज एजिस्ट नहीं
करता मान लो 404 एरर आ जाती तो तुम क्या
करते एजो स्केल का एक गिट पेज बना लेते और
इनको रिपोर्ट कर देते कि वी कैन
सक्सेसफुली अ क्या कर सकते हैं हम
सक्सेसफुली हमने कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया आपके
इस ब्रोकन लिंक के थ्रू हमने अपना खुद का
एक अटैकर का पेज यहां पे होस्ट कर दिया है
और उसपे कोई भी आएगा यहां पे तो अटैकर के
पेज प चला जाएगा एंड यह आपका लॉस है एंड
दिस इज द ट्रस्ट लॉस क्रेडिबिलिटी लॉस एंड
डिफरेंट थिंग्स तो दिस
इज ठीक है दिस इज ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग
एक्चुअल में यही होता है अब जैसे ये है
कहां पे ले जा रहा है ये एजिस्ट कोल के एक
और गेट पेज पे ले जा रहा है तो ये भी
एजिस्ट करता है तो यहां पे कोई ब्रोकन
लिंक नहीं है जनरली मतलब देखा जाए तो कोई
ब्रोकन लिंक अभी नहीं है अब जैसे यहां पे
एक है एजो स्केल का इंस्टेंस चलो इस पे
लेके चलते हैं यहां पे कुछ है अ या ऑथ
हेडर नॉट फाउंड यहां पे बट यहां पे
इंस्टेंस कीय वो है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है हमार इनके किसी लाइक उसका नहीं है इनके
किसी इंपैक्टफुल नहीं है कुछ भी यहां पर
दो लिंक्स मुझे मिले एक नेटवर्क लोड
बैलेंसर का है बिल्कुल काम कर रहा है एक
दूसरा वाला लिंक मिला यह भी काम कर रहा है
चलिए अच्छी बात है नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां
पे नीचे आते हैं नीचे आते हैं और भी चीज
देखते हैं कहां हमें क्या रीडायरेक्ट हो
रही है यह देखना है
सो चलो आ जाओ भाई नीचे आ जाओ कुछ भी नहीं
है नथिंग नथिंग क्यों भाई यार कितना बड़ा
है यार
ये ओके ओके
ओके ओके यहां पे कुछ है नहीं है नहीं है
नहीं है नीचे आ जाते हैं अ देर इज नथिंग ओ
इट्स क्वाइट
ह्यूज काफी बड़ा है ये तो एक बार नीचे आ
जाते हैं जस्ट कमिंग डाउन और इसको ना क्या
करते हैं एक बार गिट हब सर्च कर लेते हैं
गिट हब पे कई बार गिट हब के पेजेस जो होते
हैं वो कई बार एक् अवेलेबल नहीं होते तो
मैं गिट सर्च कर लेता हूं लेट्स सी कितने
है एक ही गिट हब है यहां पे अच्छा दो नहीं
है अच्छा गिट लब सर्च कर लेता हूं मैं देर
इज नो गिट लब
आल्सो एनीथिंग एल्स लिंकड
इन नहीं है यहां पर कुछ ऐसा नहीं है सो
ट्स इट कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां से निकलते
हैं उसके बाद आते हैं इस वाले पे अब यहां
पे चेक करते हैं यहां पे कुछ है क्या
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स तो व्हाट इज दिस लेट्स
ओपन इट नो नॉट ऑफ आर
यूज नीचे चलते हैं यहां पे नीचे चलते हैं
यहां पे लिमिटेशंस कुछ नहीं रजिस्टर नाउ
यह क्या करता है ये भाई रजिस्टर नाउ कहां
पर लेके जाता है अच्छा इस पर लेके जाता है
कोई बात नहीं इसको हटा देते हैं
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स में कोई आउट बन
सिक्योरिटी रूल्स है यह कुछ नहीं है
मैनेजिंग आउट बन सिक्योरिटी
रूल्स ओके नीचे आते
हैं नथिंग नथिंग नीचे आते
हैं यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं है राइट सो लेट्स
क्लोज इट लेट्स क्लोज इट यहां पर देखते
हैं यहां पर क्या ये एजो स्केल प्लेटफॉर्म
का कुछ डाटा यहां पे है यहां पे आ जाते
हैं कुछ भी यहां पे नहीं है सेस @ ex.com
है ये लीव इट यहां पे एक्सेप्ट ऑल करके
यहां पे देख लेते हैं सी द प्रोजेक्ट अब
जैसे ये क्या है ये एक प्रोजेक्ट है वार्प
प्रोजेक्ट है ये गिट अप पे रीडायरेक्ट
आपको कर रहा है तो हम इसको जरूर देखेंगे
कहीं कहीं बाय चांस ये अवेलेबल ना हो तो
हम बना लेंगे पेज जस्ट थिंग बट ये अवेलेबल
है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो चलेगा ये
सीएस प्रोजेक्ट पे चलते हैं ये अवेलेबल है
ये भी अवेलेबल है लिप रग इस पे चलते हैं
ये अवेलेबल है पब्लिक आर्काइव है
बट
सॉरी पब्लिक आर्काइव बट यह अवेलेबल तो
है इसको करते साइ पब्लिक आइ है बट अवेलेबल
है ंड ग्रेड दिस इ अवेलेबल चलिए अच्छी बात
है य अवेलेबल है यह सारे य पर बट ठीक है य
परके चलते क्या है कुछ है
[संगीत]
क्या ओके नथिंग यर डीएनएस में चलते य पर
कुछ है एसएसए की पेयर्स विंडोज लॉग इन
फायर वॉलिंग डीएनएस वाय
पोर्टल ठीक
है कछु नहीं है
भाई चलिए अब इसमें आ जाते हैं डिस्कवर
बैकअप सलूशन ठीक है इनके टीम मैनेजमेंट
वाले में भी जा जाते हैं टीम वाले में भी
ब्रोकन लिंक होते हैं जैसे टीम का अगर कोई
टीम है उस परे भी होते हैं ये
चीजें अभ ये लर्न मोर पे है जो किसी एक
थर्ड पार्टी लिंक पे हमें रीडायरेक्ट करता
है तो हम एक बार चेक कर लेंगे बाय चांस ब
यहां पे कुछ है नहीं एंड यहां पर आ रहा है
गेट इन कांटेक्ट विथ अस तो चलिए इनका
कांटेक्ट पेज देख लेते हैं कांटेक्ट पेज
पर क्या
है नथिंग मच कुछ नहीं है यहां पे टीम का
कुछ है क्या टीम का कुछ नहीं है कंपनी का
कांटेक्ट टीम का कोई ऐसा पेज तो यहां पे
नहीं
है आज की क्लास में मल्टीपल वनरे बिलिटी
होने वाली है याद रखिएगा बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम है इनका पब्लिक पब्लिक बग बाउटी
प्रोग्राम इस पर आ र है यहां पे यह क्या
है नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग मेल चेम का डाल रखा
है ठीक है और कुछ तो लिंक है नहीं ये तो
मैनुअल अप्रोच है इसका हम ऑटोमेटिक अप्रोच
भी देखेंगे लॉगइन टू कंप्ला सेंटर ठीक है
आईओ ओके यह कौन सा पेज है ओके यहां पर कुछ
भी नहीं
होगा यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पर कुछ
भी नहीं है कुछ भी नहीं है गेट इन टच विथ
अस नथिंग हियर कुछ भी नहीं है लेट्स क्लोज
इट क्लोज इट क्लोज
इट फ्रीक्वेंसी
काम का बिलो ओके फैक एफ क्य है
ये स्टेटस पेज प क्या है एगो स्टेटस है
ठीक है नथिंग हमारे काम का कुछ भी नहीं है
चलिए ओके सो कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पे
ओके ल आईम की सीएल आई एसस बकेट सीएल आई यह
सारे पेजेस ओपन कर लेंगे जितना मिले ना सब
ओपन कर लो भाई मैं यही बोलूंगा जो लिंक्स
मिले जहां मिले ओपन कर करके तुम्हें देखना
है बस तुम्हे इससे मतलब होना चाहिए कि
तुम्हें कहीं कुछ मिल तो नहीं रहा शायद
उसपे
अ नथिंग यहां पे कुछ
है ये रहा ये एक आ रही है बट ये
googleupdate.exe
ओ नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथि कुछ भी
नहीं यहां
पे कुछ ऐसा तो मुझे यहां दिख नहीं रहा है
कुछ ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं है राइट ओके जस्ट
रिमूव इट जस्ट गो यर ऑफिशियल कमांड लाइन
टूल अब यहां प एक स्केल का ये एक पेज है
ऑफिशियल कमांड लाइन टूल यहां पे है तो ये
ओबवियसली ये तो अवेलेबल होगा ही क्योंकि
इनका ऑफिशियल कमांड लाइन टूल का पेज हैय
तो यह एक्स यहां पिस्ट नहीं करता है लेट्स
सी
शमीम डेविल बॉय जो है इनको थोड़ी देर के
लिए शांत कर दीजिए आप
इनको हां यह रहा डॉकर का डॉकर का य प ए
स्ल का पेज है यहां पर शायद य कुछ ना मिले
बट है यहां पर ठीक है डकर वाली पेज है
यहां पर कुछ नहीं मिली हमें ठीक है यहां
पर क्या है ये स्कूप ड एस
ओके
ओके मेन गेट अप इं रिपोजिटरीज तो यहां कुछ
मिलेगा नहीं वैसे ऑब्जेक्ट स्टोरेज यह
कहां पे रीडायरेक्ट कर रही है हमें
विकपीडिया पे बैकअप्स कहां पे कर रही है
excel.com बैकअप पे तो ओबवियसली इट इज
रीडायरेक्टिंग टू अ गुड
लिंक तो ये मैनुअली आपको इस तरीके से
खोजते रहना है खोजते रहना है ओवरव्यू
सेक्शन में क्या है कुछ भी नहीं खोजते
रहना है मिलता है कि नहीं मिलता है खोजते
रहना है ठीक है यहां पे कुछ नहीं मिला
यहां पे क्या है कुछ भी है क्या इसका
ऑटोमेटेड वे भी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा टेंशन
नहीं लेना है आपको थोड़ा वेट कीजिए नथिंग
नथिंग नथिंग कुछ भी नहीं यहां पर राइट सो
जस्ट क्लोज इट क्लोज इट लव फ्रॉम
बांग्लादेश लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर इंडिया
से ढेरों सारा प्यार आपको एक्सप्लोर ऑल
कोर्सेस कोर्सेस प जाता है यह गेट
सर्टिफाइड सर्टिफिकेशन एग्जाम पर जाता है
यह ओके बहुत बढ़िया अब नीचे आ जाते हैं य
पे कहीं कहां पे हां यह क्या है यह भैया
ओके दिस इज कांटेक्ट आवर अकेडमी टीम टीम
को कांटेक्ट करने का है और कुछ तो यहां पर
हमें नहीं मिला राइट चलिए अच्छी बात जॉइन
द अकेडमी
हां हां 404 आया और अगर वहां प आपने अपना
पेज होस्ट कर दिया तो आपकी वो ल वल्नरेबल
हो गई अरे मतलब मैंने आपको बताया ना सिंपल
सा फंडा है यार कि इनका जैसे सोशल मीडिया
हैंडल है कोई सोशल हैंडल है कोई पता नहीं
है भी कि नहीं यार इनका मान लो ये हैंडल
है linkedin.com पे अब ये linkedin.com
मान लो ये एसो स्केल एजिस्ट नहीं कर रही
होती तो आप क्या करते आप क्या करते एको
स्केल का एक लिंगन पेज बना देते और हो गया
आप इसको दिखा देते एज अ पीओ कि भैया मैंने
ब्रोकन लिंक हाई जकिंग जो है वो फाइंड
किया आपके एक
आपके प्रोग्राम में ट्स इट
सिंपल ठीक है ये हो गया कांटेक्ट अस में
कुछ था इनका है नहीं तो इनको हटा दो कोई
और प्रोग्राम भी आप ले सकते हैं अब उसपे
ऑटोमेशन वाला एक बार चेक करेंगे अब ये तो
मैनुअल अप्रोच हो गया मैं काली लिनिक्स को
एक बार स्विच ऑन कर लेता हूं एक बार ऑन कर
लेता हूं मैं काली लिनिक्स फॉर द सम
ऑटोमेशन वर्क क्योंकि हम मैनुअली कितना
चेक करेंगे यह भी बात होती है ना कि
मैनुअली कितना कब तक चेक करेंगे आप वैसे
मैनुअल अप्रोच हमेशा परफेक्ट होती है बट
स्टिल कितना ही चेक करेंगे तो हम एक बार
ओपन कर लेते हैं काली को
राइट ओके सो काली इज
ओपन नाउ काली हमारा ओपन हो चुका
है चलिए अब काली को जैसे आप ओपन कर लेंगे
देयर इज अ ऑटोमेशन टूल फॉर दिस ब्रोकन
लिंक हाईजैकिंग जो कि काफी बढ़िया टूल है
आपको काफी मजा आएगा
उसमें ठीक है तो मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
यहां पे ब्राउजर ओपन कर लेता
हूं ओके यहां पे आपको सर्च करना है
ब्रोकेन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग गिट हब य आपको सर्च कर लेना है
ठीक
है एंड यहां पर आपको ब्रोकन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग का टूल मिल जाना चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल
से ब्रोकन लिंक हाई जैकर सर्च कर
लो या आई थिंक
दे
य कर लेते हैं
ब्रोकन
लिंक चेकर यह वाली है ब्रोकन लिंक चेकर इस
वाले रिपोजिटरी प आ जागा ठीक है ब्रोकन
लिंक चेकर कम टू दिस रिपोजिटरी दिस इ
रियली ग्रेट टूल एंड आपको इसको इंस्टॉल कर
लेना है इंस्टॉल करने के लिए आपको सिंपली
एनपीएम जो है उसको इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा
पहले तो आप अपने काली मशीन में जब एनपीएम
को इंस्टॉल कीजिएगा तो आपको एक काम करना
पड़ेगा आपको पहले तो एप्ट अपडेट कमांड चला
दे ठीक है याद रखिएगा एप्ट अपडेट कमांड
चला दीजिएगा देन उसके बाद आप एप्ट सॉरी यह
मैंने चला दी क्या ओके मैंने ऑलरेडी चलाया
हुआ था बट स्टल ठीक
है इसको एक बार बंद कर दू क्या देख लेते
हैं ज्यादा टाइम लेगा तो बंद कर देंगे ब
ज्यादा टाइम लेना नहीं चाहिए क्योंकि
रिसेंटली अपडेट हुई थी
य
यस तो एट अपडेट चला दीजिएगा उसके बाद आप
पट अपग्रेड चला दीजिएगा यह कमांड थोड़ा
टाइम लगेगा प अपग्रेड में होने में जो भी
अपग्रेडेबल पैकेज है वो अपग्रेड हो जाएंगे
आपके ठीक
है सो लेट्स
वेट हां जी तो अब यहां पे एप्ट अपग्रेड कर
दीजिएगा यह कमांड चला दीजिएगा उसके बाद आप
एन
पीएम सॉरी एप्ट इंस्टॉल एनपीएम ये चला
दीजिएगा तो आपका एनपीएम पैकेज जो है वो
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा आई थिंक इंस्टॉल था ये
पैकेज ऑलरेडी
अ ओके ओके डन एनपीए ठीक है सो एक बार फिर
से मैं चेक कर एनपीएम चेक है ना हां
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है एंड इसके बाद आप यह
कमांड चला दीजिएगा कौन सा कमांड चलाना है
आपको यह वाला एनपीएम इंस्टॉल ब्रोकन लिंक
चेकर इसको कॉपी कीजिए एंड इसको यहां पे ये
चीज चला दीजिए ठीक है जैसे आप एंटर करेंगे
यह आपका इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा एंड उसके बाद आप
ब्रोकन लिंक चेकर को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं
ब्रोकन लिंक चेकर हान h से आप इस टूल को
स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं तो ये टूल इस तरीके
से स्टार्ट हो जाता है सो बेसिकली इसका
यूसेज जो है वो बीएलसी शॉर्ट फॉर्म में आप
कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट बीएलसी दिस वन एंड
हान एच करेंगे तो भी आपको यही टूल ओपन
होगा बीएलसी या ब्रोकन लिंक पूरा ही लिख
सकते हैं इसको यूज़ करना कैसे है बीएलसी
कर दीजिए उसके बाद आपको टारगेट यहां पे
डाल देना है जो भी आपका टारगेट है आप चेक
कर लीजिए आप उसको यूज टारगेट को यहां पे
मेंशन कर दीजिए क्या है टारगेट कोई सा भी
एक टारगेट उठा लेते हैं बक राउट से ठीक है
तो हमने इस तो दे एजो स्केल में देखा इसको
हम हटा देते हैं कोई और टारगेट प्रोग्राम
कोई और प्रोग्राम प देखते हैं रबल देखते
हैं क्या है ये वाइटर देखते हैं इसको
रैपिड है जो है वह भी है बट ठीक है अभी
हटाओ रैपिड को काफी लोग आ चुके होंगे
रैपिड में तो इन दोनों में देखते हैं रेबल
में कोई वेबसाइट है क्या
इनके हां
जी मेन वेबसाइट है बाकी बहुत सारे सब डोमस
है ओके तो मेन वेबसाइट है रिबल कॉ तो मैं
इस पूरी वेबसाइट को ही यहां पर टारगेट में
रख लेता हूं तो यहां पर सॉरी यहां पर आपको
वेबसाइट मेंशन कर देनी है तो मैंने यहां
परडी पीस रेबल मेंशन कर दिया उसके बाद
आपको ऑप्शन कुछ लगा देने हैं जैसे मैं
यहां पे हान आर लगा दूंगा रिकसिव के लिए
हान आर देन हान ओ लगा दूंगा
ऑर्डर डर्ड यहां पर लि लाक डर्ड वे में जो
लिंक्स है उन अपीयर होने का उसके लिए
यह तो आपकी हो गई उसके बाद यहां पर मैं और
क्या लगा सकता हूं वर्वस मोड आप लगा सकते
हैं
नवी जो एक्सक्लूडेड लिंक्स है उनको
दिखाएगा नवी अगर आप लगाते हैं तो ठीक है
तो जो भी एक्सक्लूड किए गए लिंक्स उनको यह
दिखा देगा उसके बाद आप लगा सकते हैं यहां
पर फिल्टर लेवल सेट कर सकते हैं इसमें
फिल्टर लेवल में क्या हो जाता
है स्क्रीन प्रॉपर नहीं दिख रहा है क्या
बोल रहे हो भाई
यार
स्क्रीन नहीं दिख रही है क्या आप लोगों
को स्क्रीन नहीं दिख रही है क्या बताओ जरा
एक बार यार स्क्रीन क्यों नहीं दिखेगी
क्यों डिस्टर्ब करते हो यार तुम लोग झूट
मूट
का स्क्रीन नहीं दिख रही बताइए
मुझे कौशिक थ कौशिक थैंक
यू इट्स विजिबल ठीक
है ओके ठीक है चलिए कमांड जो लिख
रहा वो दिखेगी यार ऊपर अभी दिखेगी
अभी वह कमांड ऊपर दिख जाएगी ठीक है तो चलो
मैं न्यू यहां पर मैं न्यू टैब में ओपन कर
लेता हूं यहां
पर एंड यहां पे आपको बी ब्रोकन लिंक चेकर
यह डालना है आपको एंड देन आपको अपना
टारगेट यहां पे डाल देना है तो यह रहा
टारगेट मेरा rb.com उसके बाद मैं हान आरओ
लगा दूंगा रिकर्स एंड ऑर्डर्स है वो लगा
दूंगा फिल्टर लेवल सेट कर सकते हैं जैसे
क्लिकब्रिक्स
फॉर्म्स सब सारे कुछ करने हैं तो आप लगा
सकते हैं ये चीज डिफॉल्ट वन है आपका जो
डिफॉल्ट इसका है मतलब रो प्लस मीडिया आई
फ्रेम मेटा डाटा रिफे सब कुछ तो मैं सिर्फ
अभी
क्लिकब्रिक्स
केबल लिंक्स
दैट्ची
एडीपीएस थिंग एक बार ट्राई करते हैं इसको
रिमूव करके ल क इनपुट यूआरएल
रिक्वायर्ड ठीक है सो हमें चाहिए य
एडीपीएस कॉलन स्ल स्ल देते
हैं ओके यह ले नहीं रहा है तो यहां पर मैं
एक बार बीएलसी की जगह ब्रोकन करके देख
लेता
हूं या सो इट्स नॉट गेटिंग एनी लिंक्स
फ्रॉम दिस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल राइट तो एक
काम कर लेते हैं यहां पर हम एक बार यूआरएल
चेंज करके देखते हैं लेट्स चेंज द यूआरएल
सो डिबल कॉ पर कुछ हमें मिल नहीं रहा इसको
मैनुअल चेक कर लेंगे अगर यहां पर ऐसे कुछ
नहीं मिल रहा तो ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बाकी कोई और भी उस पर देख सकते हैं
टेबल
कॉ डबल कॉ इस पर ट्राई आउट कर लेते हैं
शायद इन्होंने इसको बना रखा हो या एक बार
फिल्टर लेबल हटा देते हैं एक बार फिल्टर
लेबल हटा के चेक कर लेते हैं इफ य आर
गेटिंग समथिंग नो तो हमने यहां पर इसको जो
है इसको मूव करते हैं ए यहां पर टेस्टल कॉ
करते
हैं
ओके एचटीटीपी एस कॉलन
स् ओके सो वी आर नॉट गेटिंग दिस एनी लिंक
फ्रॉम दिस एक काम करते हैं एक बार चेंज
करते
इसको वाइटर इसमें क्या सीन है वाइटर
में
ओके वेबसाइट में है यहां पर इनके सारे सब
डोमस प
है ट्रक कॉ लेट्स ओपन इट क्या है
य ओ लेट्स प्रोवाइड दिस
वन लेट सी न दि आर नॉट एक्सेप्टिंग दिस वन
सो एक काम करते हैं एक कोई दूसरा एक बार
ट्राई करते हैं देख के कि सबके साथ हो रहा
है या इसके साथ ही हो रहा है
जैसे क्लास डोजो
अटलास चिया नेटवर्क सो चिया का क्या
सिस्टम है भाई चिया कोर चिया यहां पे क्या
क्लास डोजो व्हाट इज दिस क्लास डोजो .
क्सड zoo.com
क्लास क्सड zoo.com ये मेन वेबसाइट है
इनकी
तो मेन वेबसाइट जो है इसको कॉपी कर लेते
हैं क्लास डोजो का ये क्या हुआ भाई क्या
ओपन हुआ
ये
ओके लेट्स कॉपी द मेन वेबसाइट क्लास
डोजो हां हां हां हा उसे भी बट यह ब्रोकन
लिंक स्पेशली चेक करेगा स्पेशली ट्स वा
इट्स
गुड चलिए यहां पर हम यह वाली लिंक डाल
देते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इ है
ओके सो यस यह काम कर रहा है यहां पे उन
लिंक्स के साथ काम नहीं कर रहा था तो यहां
पे हमारा एक टारगेट है क्लास do.com तो अब
ये क्या है कि जितने भी लिंक्स हैं यह
सबको निकाल रहा है एंड ब्रोकन लिंक ट्राई
करेगा फाइंड करने का बेसिकली ठीक है तो ये
सारे लिंक्स ओके ओके जो बता रहा है तो
बेसिकली दीज लिंक्स आर टोटली ओके नो
ब्रोकन लिंक्स आर हियर इन दिस लिंक्स तो
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा राइट तो अब अगर
कोई ब्रोकन लिंक यह फाइंड करता है इस
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट साइट के अंदर में किसी
भी तरह का कोई तो आपको ये बता देगा फिर
आपको देखना है कि उस ब्रोकन लिंक से
बेसिकली आप कुछ इंपैक्टफुल कुछ कर सकते
हैं कि नहीं कर सकते अब ऐसा मान लो कोई
सीडीएन का लिंक है वो ब्रोकन है तो वहां
पे आप क्या कर लोगे वहां तो आप कुछ नहीं
कर सकते हो जनरली आप या कोई होस्ट होस्टेड
वेबसाइट का कोई सर्वर का कोई पेज है मान
लो तो वो तो आप कुछ नहीं कर सकते ना अगर
वो ब्रोकन है तो आप जाके उसके अकाउंट में
सर्वर सर्वर लॉगिन करके वहां पे तो कोई
पेज क्रिएट नहीं कर सकते उसके लिए आपको
सर्वर एक्सेस चाहिए तो वो एक इंपैक्टफुल
नहीं हुआ लेकिन कोई गिट हब का पेज हुआ कोई
सोशल मीडिया हैंडल हो गई कोई एक्सटर्नल
साइट हो गई जहां पर आप जाके अकाउंट क्रिएट
कर सकते हो एक फेक अकाउंट तो वो फिर आपका
ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग में कंसीडर हो
जाएगा ठीक
है ओके तो देखिए यहां पे यहां पे एक यहां
पे एक मिला हमें क्लास डोजो का ब्रोकन है
बट यह 403 है शट शट शट
शट ये 403 है सो आई डोंट थिंक बट स्टिल
हमें एक लिंक मिला है twitter.com क्लास
डोजो 403 पे जा रहा है ये आई थिंक तो इट्स
रीडायरेक्टिंग हियर क्लास डोजो ये शायद
ओपन प्रोफाइल है इनका ओके दिस इज ओके
क्लास डोजो पे ये रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा
था सो दिस इज अ फाल्स पॉजिटिव यू कैन से
क्योंकि क्लास डोजो एजिस्ट कर रही है राइट
क्लास डोजो इज एसिस्टिंग आप देख सकते हो
यहां पे क्लास डोजो एजिस्ट कर रहा है बट
या फाल्स पॉजिटिव था तो इग्नोर करेंगे कोई
बात नहीं कभी-कभी फाल्स पॉजिटिव मिल
जाएंगे आपको तो इग्नोर कर लीजिएगा उसको
ठीक है तो एक आपको मिला था यहां पे यहां
पे एक और है तो यह भी सेम है सेम फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है यहां
पे नीचे आ जाते हैं
twitter.com क्लास डज सेम है ये
twitter.com क्लास डज सेम चीज है ये सेम
ही सेम है यहां
पे सर आई हैव शेयर्ड योर चैनल अ सर आई हैव
ओके शेयर्ड योर चैनल विथ माय फ्रेंड्स दे
जस्ट स्टार्टेड देर न्यू बग बाउटी जर्नी
दे जस्ट लव हाउ टू मेक दिस जर्नी सो
इंटरेस्टिंग ग्रेट थैंक
यू ओके एक और ब्रोकन मिला आईपीसी ऑन
सीडब्ल्यूपी कंटेंट रिसोर्सेस फंडामेंटल
प्रिंसिपल पीडीएफ बट इससे कोई फायदा हमें
नहीं होने वाला है क्योंकि हम इनके सर्वर
साइड जाकर अपलोड तो नहीं कर सकते ना
पर्टिकुलर फाइल तो यह कंसीडरेबल नहीं होगा
ठीक
है
ओके नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे व्हाट इज दिस
डेली डज . कॉ व्हाट इज दिस न्यूजलेटर क्या
है ये न्यूजलेटर
भाई ओके दिस इज अ न्यूज लेटर थिंग तो
हमारे किसी काम का वैसे भी नहीं
है प्राइम लीडर्स स्कूल रिक्रूटमेंट कुछ
नहीं है हमारा क्लास डोजो फिर से वही चीज
है क्लास डोजो ओके क्लास
डोजो नथि तो मतलब इस तरीके से आपको करना
है एक्सप्लोर करना है एक्सपीरियंस करना है
करते रहना है ट्राई करते रहना है मे बी यू
गेट सम अ ब्रोकन लिंक फॉर योर प्रोग्राम
राइट ओके ओके ओके
ओके क्या बोल हो भाई ईमेल आईडी भी ब्रोकन
लिंक में आ जाएगा मतलब किस टाइप का ईमेल
आईडी है तो बताओ मल अगर कोई है अगर उस
टाइप से लाइक इंपैक्टफुल तो
जरूर ओके देर इज अ देर इज अ कमेंट यर आई
पेड र बांटी बट डिड नॉट गेट सो मच कंटेंट
च आई गेट फ्रॉम योर चैनल द क्वालिटी च आई
रिसीव इज ब्रिलियंट इ जस्ट लाइक अ बेबी
स्टेप फॉर अस थैंक यू थैंक यू ब्रदर ऐसे
ही तो सिखाना है एकदम बच्चों जैसे सिखाना
है ताकि हर बंदा सीखे जो ऑलरेडी एक्सपर्ट
है उनके लिए तो है ही नहीं
य जो बिल्कुल नहीं जानते उनके लिए है यह
सीरीज पूरी तो यहां पर एक ब्रोकर मिला
मुझे ओ पॉलिसी हाईलाइट मुझे मिला ब 403
हैय
ब्रोकन
ठीक
है सर मुझे पी फ मिला था टफ प आपको टैग भी
किया था लिंकन प ओके ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशन
अगर आपको मिल रहा है तो यह कांग्रेचुलेशन
वाली बात है सिंपल सी सिंपल सा फंडा है
आपको पी फ मिल रहा है इनफॉर्मेटिव मिल रहा
है मतलब वैलिड बग है आप यह सोचिए ट्स अ
वैलिड बग
एक्चुअली
सो ग्रेट ब्रेव बी
गेमिंग चलिए यह तो चलो ब्रोकेन लिंक यहां
पे यह अपना काम कर रहा है इसको इसको होने
देते हैं इसमें टाइम लग जाएगा ऐसे करके तो
मतलब आप अपना जो भी है लिंक्स को चेक आउट
करते रहिएगा सिंपल यहां पे मोस्टली जो है
फुटर में आपको ऐसे लिंक्स मिलेंगे बहुत
सारे जहां प जैसे अब
ऑल ऑफ लव इस पे कर रहा है इन सब पे आपको
कांटेक्ट हेल्प डेस्क सब पे आप मैनुअली भी
जा जाके चेक आउट कर सकते हैं तो बिल्कुल
इनके
twitter's पे मिल रही है क्या कुछ जाके तो
यहां पे आप देख सकते हो करियर्स पे आप
यहां पे आते हैं यहां पे डोजो गेट जॉब्स
तो यहां पर आप आ सकते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पर चेक आउट कर सकते हैं कुछ और यहां
पर मिल रहा है क्या अगर कुछ ब्रोकन टाइप
कुछ मिल रहा है तो तो यू कैन चेक आउट तो
मैनुअली चेक करोगे मेरे ख्याल से ज्यादा
बढ़िया रहता है मैं ऐसा बिलीव करता हूं इन
सब चीजों में मैनुअल प्रो ज्यादा बेटर
होता है आपकी एफिशिएंसी लाइक आपकी जो
एक्यूरेसी है वो मेरे ख्याल से ज्यादा हो
जाती है उस केस में ठीक है तो आप यह काम
कीजिएगा दिस
इ
दिस इज
कॉल्ड ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग ठीक है आई
होप यू ऑल गट इट सिंपल अब यह किसी भी पेज
पर हो सकता है कोई भी एक लिंक जो डेड है
लिंक जो एजिस्ट नहीं करती है उस पर आप
अकाउंट क्रिएट कर सकते हैं एंड आप उस परे
जाके आप उसको रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं सिंपल
सा फंडा है और कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है बस
ट्स
इट ठीक है क्लास्ट आपको रेक अप कर देता
हूं यहां पे जैसे ये एक पेज है मान लो कोई
एक यहां पेज है यहां पे गिट पे किसी
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है किसी गिट हप पेज पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है कोई भी पेज एंड गिट
पे वो पेज एजिस्ट नहीं करती है तो आप गिट
पे वो पेज बना के वो रिपोजिटरी बना के आप
उसको यहां पे रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं कि भैया
देखो आपके वेबसाइट से कोई उस पेज पे जाएगा
गट वाले तो इस पे आ जाएगा जो कि एक मेरा
पेज है मेरा खुद का कन्फर पेज है ठीक है
इस तरीके से चलिए तो दिस वन इज
डन ओके चलिए हो गया अ यहां पे कनेक्ट
वॉलेट यहां पे कुछ है क्या इनके में
सेल्स का यहां पर आ रहा है यहां पर कुछ
मार्केटिंग का यहां पे होम पेज का आ रहा
है तो य तो रि होम पेज प चले जाएंगे यहां
पर चले जाते हैं नाउ यर इज
[संगीत]
पे जाते हैं ये ब्लॉग पे अब जैसे मान लो
ये
फाइंड इट अगर कुछ मिलता है तो यह आपको
यहां पे प्रोवाइड कर देगा राइट तो हमें
कुछ यहां पे फिलहाल यहां इसमें कुछ नहीं
मिला है तो आप अपने अपने टारगेट के लिए
इसको यूज कर सकते
हैं चलिए तो यह था ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग
उसके बाद ब्रोकन लिंक हाईजैकिंग के बाद
आपका जो नेक्स्ट हम लेते हैं ओरिजिन आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर अब ये ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर
काफी ज्यादा काफी ज्यादा यूजफुल हो सकता
है आपके लिए जैसे आप ओरिजिन आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर से आप मास डीडीएस अटैक कर सकते
हैं एक्सस जैसी एबिलिटीज फाइंड कर सकते
हैं एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन जैसी वनबिल फाइंड
कर सकते हैं पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट पैरामीटर पे
ठीक है अगर आपका आईपी डिस्क्लोजर हो जाता
है ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर हो जाता है तब
ठीक है अ कैन फाइंड हिडन
पोर्ट्स ठीक है ये सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं
अब आप खुद सोचो यार मान लो मेरी मेरी देखो
जैसे मेरी क्या है मेरी वेबसाइट है ठीक है
मैं क्या करता हूं मेरी वेबसाइट पे चलता
हूं टेक्निकल n गटर आ मैं इस वेबसाइट पे
चलता हूं ये हमारी वेबसाइट है ब्लॉक पेज
जो है हमारी जिसम आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी
रिलेटेड ब्लॉक्स काफी सारे पढ़ सकते हैं
सो मान लो मैंने यह पेज मैंने यह ओपन ओपन
किया तो दिस इज ओरिजन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर ठीक
है मैंने ये ओपन कर लिया अब मैं इसको क्या
करूंगा मैं पिंक करूंगा भाई मुझे इसकी
आईपी फाइंड करनी है तो आई विल बी पिंग दिस
चलिए तो हम इसको पिंग कर लेते हैं पिंग न
4 मैंने ये डाला एंड मैंने पिंग किया
सॉरी सो आई एम पिंग जैसे मैंने पिंग किया
मुझे एक आईपी एड्रेस मिल गई 10 0 4218 अब
यह आईपी एक्चुअल में मेरी आईपी है क्या
चलो मैं इस इसको क्या करता
हूं एंटर करता हूं एंड एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश करता हूं जैसे ही मैं एक्सेस करने
की कोशिश करता हूं मेरी वेबसाइट को इट्स
सेइंग एरर
1003 एंड डायरेक्ट आईपी एक्सेस नॉट अलाउड
क्यों क्योंकि मेरी वेबसाइट एक सीडीएन
पे सीडीएन के थ्रू होके कंटेंट को फेच
करती है सीडीएन के थ्रू कंटेंट फेच होता
है हमारी वेबसाइट के ऊपर में सीडीएन ट जो
है वो क्लाउड फ्लेर का है ठीक है तो यानी
कि हमारी वेबसाइट है फिर क्लाउड फ्लेयर है
और फिर आपका सर्वर है तो इस तरीके से आपका
यह काम कर रहा है तो आप डायरेक्टली हमारी
वेबसाइट को एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते आपको
क्लाउड फ्लेयर के हो के थ्रू होके जाना
पड़ेगा उनके सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म के थ्रू
होके जाना पड़ेगा तो बहुत सारी
सिक्योरिटीज मैकेनिज्म वहां काम करती है
बहुत सारी चीजों को आप एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर
सकते वन बिटीज फाइंड नहीं कर सकते उस केस
में ठीक है सिंपल सा फंडा है अब मुझे इसका
मुझे ओरिजिनल आईपी अगर मान लो निकालनी है
लेट्स सपोज आई नीड टू फाइंड ओरिजिनल आईपी
ऑफ आवर अ वेबसाइट तो उस केस में मैं क्या
करूंगा उस केस में मेरे पास मल्टीपल
ऑप्शंस है उस केस में मेरे पास एक अलग-अलग
तरीके हैं मैं उसको आजमा ंगा ठीक है इसको
फाइंड करने का तो सबसे पहले मैं क्या
करूंगा गाइस आई विल बी यूजिंग शान मैं शान
का यूज करूंगा एंड शान से मैं ट्राई
करूंगा इसको फाइंड करने का जैसे मैं क्या
करूंगा होस्ट नेम डालूंगा होस्ट नेम एंड
मैं यहां डालूंगा टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर ड आ अब देखते हैं यहां पे होस्ट
नेम में टेक्निकल नेविगेटर ड आय करके
रिजल्ट कुछ आता है कि नहीं आता है लेट्स
सी तो कोई रिजल्ट नहीं मिली क्योंकि हमारी
वेबसाइट छोटी सी है मैं कोई बड़ा टारगेट
हम लेके चलते हैं मान लो कोई कोई एक बड़ा
टारगेट रखते हैं जिसकी आईपी जो है हमें
फाइंड करनी है किसी एक टारगेट की राइट तो
हम क्ला dj.com को ही फाइंड कर लेते हैं
ट्राई कर लेते हैं तो मैं क्या करता हूं
क्लास do.com को यहां से कॉपी किया और
यहां पे देखते हैं कि इसका कौन सा आईपी
हमें मिलता है तो हमने पिंग किया क्लास
do.com को एंड लेट्स सी व्ट आईपी वी आर
गेटिंग इज इट डायरेक्टली एक्सेसिबल र नॉट
सो हमें एक आईपी मिल रही है दिस आईपी
लेट्स सी कौन सी किस टाइप की आईपी है ये
डायरेक्टे बल एक्सेस डायरेक्टली एक्सेसिबल
है या सीडीएन के पीछे है तो ये ये सिंपल
सी चीज है कि 403 एरर आपके आ रहा है वी
कैन नॉट कनेक्ट टू द सर्वर फॉर दिस प और
वेबसाइट दिस टाइम दिस माइट बी टू मच
ट्रैफिक और कन्फेशन एरर ट्राई दिस लेटर
ठीक है ये हमें मिला क्योंकि हमें ये
क्लाउड फ्रंट यहां पर यूज हो रही है तो ये
एक पीछे में है किसी पर्टिकुलर सीडीएन के
पीछे में ठीक है तो क्लाउड फं के पीछे ये
यूज हो रहा है तो अब मुझे क्या करूंगा मैं
यहां पे क्ला do.com मैं यहां पे चलूंगा
शान पे एंड होस्ट नेम में मैं यहां पे
क्सड zoo.com डाल दूंगा ठीक
है क्लास डोजो क एंड ट्राई करूंगा कुछ
मिलता है कि नहीं हमें रिजल्ट्स में दे
लेट्स सी सो जैसे ही मैंने यहां पे क्लास
dj.com किया हमें कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं
एंड वी गेट द रिजल्ट्स हियर कुछ आईपी यहां
पे हमें मिल रही है रिजल्ट्स के फॉर्म में
ठीक है तो अब क्या करेंगे हम इन आईपीस को
एक बार एक्सेस करेंगे एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट
आईपी क्या है ये एडवांस एक्सेप्ट ंड
कंटिन्यू लेट्स सी क्या एक्सेस कर पा रहे
हैं कुछ नहीं है 404 है कोई एक्सेसिबल कुछ
नहीं है चलिए अच्छी बात है इसको एक्सेस
करते हैं यहां पे देखते हैं अगर हमने
क्लास डोजो को एक्सेस कर लिया इनके थ्रू
इनके सर्विस को तो फिर ये एक लेबिलिटी है
हमने उनका एक्सेस डायरेक्टली एक्सेस किया
है उनके आईपी से सो लेट्स सी ओके व्हाट
दिस आईपी इज
ओपनिंग यह आईपी है यह भी है यह भी है यह
भी है यह भी है यह भी है यह भी है यह भी
है चलिए नेक्स्ट प चलते हैं यहां
पे दिस वन दिस वन दिस वन दिस वन दिस वन
दिस वन दिस वन चलिए इतने आ गए अब यहां पर
ये तो ओपन नहीं हो रहा इसको हटा देते हैं
यहां पर एडवांस करते हैं यहां पर एक्सेप्ट
रिस्क एंड कंटिन्यू करते हैं सो व्हाट वी
गेटिंग
हियर नथिंग एडवांस प करते एक्सेप्ट रिस्क
एंड
कंटिन्यू लेट्स
सी ओके व्ट इ दिस वेलकम इवन मॉनिटर साइट
है यहां पे ठीक है लर्न अबाउट वे ओके कुछ
है नहीं यहां प बट स्टिल चलिए देख लेते
कंटिन्यू करते देखते कहां प जाते है ओ सो
नथिंग कुछ नहीं है कुछ भी नहीं है कुछ भी
नहीं है अगेन यहां पर वनिंग आ एक्सेप्ट
स्क एंड
कंटिन्यू हां हां कर सकते शान का ब्राउजर
एक्सटेंशन यूज कर सकते हैं सो यह कहीं प
जा रहा है कहीं प नहीं जा रहा एडवांस में
करते एक्सेप्ट ंड
कंटिन्यू क्या ये एनोनिमस इ नॉट अराइज टू
परफॉर्म बिकॉज नो रिसोर्स ठीक है यहां पे
एनोनिमस को इन्होंने ऑथराइज नहीं किया है
चलिए अच्छी बात है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
यहां पे कुछ नहीं यहां पे कुछ नहीं कुछ
नहीं कुछ नहीं कुछ नहीं कुछ नहीं अगेन
यहां पे एक मिला हमें एक्सेप्ट कर लेते
हैं यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पे कुछ
भी नहीं है सो डन सो इस तरीके से हमें
फाइंड करना है राइट तो हमने क्लास डोजो पे
फाइंड किया हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास मिला
नहीं अब इसके अलावा एक और वेबसाइट है अ
लाइक सर्च डॉट सेंस आ दिस यू कैन यूज दिस
वेबसाइट आल्सो
search.com एक और कोई टारगेट हम ले लेते
हैं क्लास जोज तो हमने ऑलरेडी कर लिया
अलासन के लिए वी कैन टेक इफ यू
वांट
सॉरी लास्ट tel.com तो यह ले लेते हैं हम
एक बार एंड वेरीफाई कर लेते हैं
इसको ठीक है तो आप यहां पे भी डाल सकते
हैं वेबसाइट एंड यहां पे सर्च कर सकते हैं
अगर कुछ आपको यहां पर मिलता है कुछ रिजल्ट
आपको मिलते हैं यहां पर सो यर वी गेट सम
रिजल्ट्स यहां पर दिस आईपी सो हमें आईपी
मिली है यह वाली आईपी मिली है पता नहीं इस
आईपी प क्या है तो चलिए एक बार एक्सेस
करके देख लेते हैं व्ट इज द थिंग वी आर
गेटिंग न दिस
आईपी ओके कुछ भी नहीं मिल रहा य प हम
होस्ट नेम में यहां प अगेन वी कैन चेंज इट
टू सॉरी होस्ट नेम में हम यहां पर क्या
चेंज करेंगे भैया वी आर गोइंग टू
चेंज दिस वन इन होस्ट नेम राइट यहां एंटर
कर लेते हैं देखते हैं क्या रिजल्ट्स हमें
मिलते हैं शान पे इसके जगह पे आप जम आई को
भी यूज कर सकते हो इफ यू वांट यू कैन यूज
द जम आई आल्सो ठीक है तो यहां कुछ भी नहीं
मिला हमें जम आई करके वेबसाइट है उसको भी
आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो ठीक है तो चलिए
अब यहां तो हमें मिल गया यह चीज हमें मिल
रही है मान लो अब हम यहां पे क्या करते
हैं ना लेट्स गो टू netflix.com
netflix.com
ठीक है ये ओपन हुआ netflix.com प चलते हैं
यहां पर पिंग कर लेते हैं fx.com को ओके
सॉरी तो यहां पर हम पिंग न 4 netflix.com
प चलते हैं एंड यहां पर हमें एक आईपी मिल
गई है यह वाली आईपी मिली हमें चलिए देखते
हैं डायरेक्ट आईपी एक्सेस अलाउड है कि
नहीं इस सो यह ब्लॉकड हैय आप देख सकते य
दिस इ ब्लॉकड ऐसा कुछ आ रहा है तो हम
netflix.com प ऐसा सेम ट्राई कर सकते हैं
वी कैन गो एंड ट्रा ट्राई आउट र
netflix.com तो हम शान में य प होस्ट नेम
य
क डाल देंगे एन ा
करेंगे सो सी गेट
समथिंग ओके बढ़िया टेक्निकल जस व्ट अबाउट
नस मिस कन्फेशन लाएंगे यार
लाएंगे एई बग बांटी का क्या करेगी अरे व
तो बाद की बात है यार उस वीडियो मेंगा अल
से सेपरेट फॉर बिन फॉर
बिन इसको एक्सेस कर लेते हैं इसको एक्सेस
करते हैं देखते यार कहीं कुछ एक्सेस मिल
जाए
शायद लेट्स सी लेट्स सी बहुत सारी चीज
यहां पे वनिंग एडवांस एक्सेप्ट लेट्स सी
क्या होता है यहां पे ओके एक फाइल डाउनलोड
हुई है चलो कोई बात नहीं इस पे चलते हैं
एक्सेप्ट फॉर बिडेन यहां पे एडवांस चलते
हैं यहां प एक्सेप्ट रिस्क एंड
कंटिन्यू अगेन फाइल हेयर इज
[संगीत]
द ओके सो लेट्स एक्सेस दिस
पेज क्या है देखते य पर क्या भया यह
एडगार्ड है यह एडगार्ड है
रियली सो य एडगार्ड का लॉगिन पेज है यह च
टाइप ऑफ लॉगइन पेज इट इ आई एम नॉट गेटिंग
ओके ग्रेट
ग्रेट ओके एड गड का य एक लॉगिन पेज है यह
अच्छी बात है यह मिला
एडमन
एडमन एक आईपी मिली
है कंट्रोल पैनल का एक तरह से एडगार्ड का
तो अच्छी बात है ऐसे कुछ कुछ मिल जाती है
कभी कभी तो एक्सेप्ट एंड कंटिन्यू यहां पर
चलते हैं यहां पेज डाउनलोड हो रहा है यहां
पर एडवांस प चलते
हैं पेज डाउनलोड ई य एडवांस प चलते य
एक्सेप्ट न
कंटिन्यू अगेन सेम चीज एडवांस
एक्सेप्ट ओके चन चन सेम चीज एडवांस
एक्सेप्ट सॉरी सो नथिंग मच यहां पे कुछ
हमें मिला नहीं तो आपको अब देखो जैसे अब
मेरे पास मेरी जो वेबसाइट है मेरी
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर है तो इसकी आईपी आपको
जो मिल रही थी तो डायरेक्ट आईपी एक्सेस
ब्लॉक था सिंपल सा मैंने जब मेरी वेबसाइट
का आईपी निकाला यहां पे मैंने जब यहां पे
पिंग किया टेक्निकल नेविगेटर को तो मेरे
को जो आईपी मिली यह वाली आईपी तो मैं इसको
जब एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं मेरी
वेबसाइट की आईपी को ओरिजिनल ये आईपी मिल
रही है तो ये आ रहा है डायरेक्ट आईपी
एक्सेस अलाउड नहीं है अब मुझे इसका रियल
आईपी निकालना है तो एक तो मैं किसका यूज़
करूंगा एक तो मैं शन का यूज़ करूंगा होस्ट
नेम में डाल के चक ट्राई करूंगा देन मैं
सेंसस search.in आयो का यूज़ करूंगा इसमें
ट्राई करूंगा मैं जूम आ का ट्राई करूंगा
मैं जम आ का आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं यहां पे
भी आप अपना होस्ट नेम या जो भी आपका
यूआरएल है आप डाल के ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं इफ यू आर गेटिंग सम रिजल्ट्स एंड इफ
यू आर गेटिंग सम आईपीस एंड ऑल जो एक्सेस
करने पे आप उस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट को
एक्सेस कर पा रहे हो तो वो ओरिजनल आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर आपका हो जाता है तो आप इनका
यूज कर सकते हो इसके साथ-साथ ना आप एक और
चीज का यूज कर सकते हो यू कैन ट्राई एंड
चेक फॉर एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड उस पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट का उसमें कई बार डिस्क्लोज हो
जाता है आपकी आईपी जैसे मतलब कई बार होता
है जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं मैं चलता हूं
किटर मैन
पे किटर मैन पे चलता हूं मैं यहां पे एक
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड टेस्टिंग वेबसाइट
है मैं एसपीएफ के बारे में आपको बता दूंगा
क्या है क्या क्या चीज है ये तो मैं यहां
पे डोमेन डाल देता हूं डोमेन में अपनी
वेबसाइट डाल देता हूं मैं चलिए
टेक्निकल नेगर आ मैंने यहां पे एंटर किया
अब ये जो है एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड मेरे को यहां
पे लेकर ला रहा है एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड जो होती
है सेंडर्स पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क इसको बोलते
हैं ये मेल के ऑथेंटिकेशन को चेक करने के
लिए एक बेसिकली अ स्टैंडर्ड है एसपीएफ जो
कि डीएनएस के टी एक्सटी रिकॉर्ड के अंदर
मेंशन किया जाता है यानी कि अगर आप इसको
मेंशन करके रखते हैं तो दिस विल अ दिस विल
अलाउ कि आपके डोमेन से जो मेल आती है वह
ऑथेंटिकली आप तक पहुंच रही है एंड मतलब
कोई स्पैम नहीं हो रहा उसके थ्रू तो यह
वेरीफाई करती है हमारा एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड ठीक
है सेंडर्स पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क होता है मेल
ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए जनरली यूज़ में ली जाती
है ठीक है अब यहां पे अगर किसी वेबसाइट का
मैं इस पे भी आऊंगा एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड भी
हमारा जो है इस बग के अंदर कवर करूंगा कवर
है एक्चुअली तो यहां पे हमें मिल रहा है
फाउंड वर्जन = एए 1 रिकॉर्ड टेक्निकल एक
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड मिला मुझे एंड एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड में वर्जन एसपीएफ व एमए एमए
रिकॉर्ड के लिए ए रिकॉर्ड के लिए आईपी
वर्जन 4 अब देखो यहां पे एक तुम्हें आईपी
मिल रही है एंड ये आईपी तुम्हें मिल रही
है एक देखो ये एक डिफरेंट आईपी मिल रही है
जो तुम्हें आईपी जनरली मिल रही है ना
जनरली जो तुम्हें आईपी मिली थी यहां से
आईपी क्या मिली थी ये 104 बट हमें अभी जो
आईपी मिली है वो ये आईपी मिल रही है तो ये
एक डिस्क्लोजर हुआ आईपी का अब ये जो आईपी
है ये आईपी एक्चुअली आपके सर्वर की आईपी
हो सकती है
दिस आईपी कैन बी द एक्चुअल आईपी ऑफ दैट
वेबसाइट तो इस तरीके से भी आप ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड के अंदर भी
फाइंड आउट करके आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है
चलिए यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा मेरे
ख्याल से बहुत ही सिंपल सा है इजी सा है
तो तीन चार तरीके हो गए शान का यूज करके
हो गया जम का सेंसस का यूज करके एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड का यूज करके आप ट्राई आट कर सकते
हैं तो यहां प डिस्क्लोजर हो सकता है यहां
पे अब मैं यहां पर netflix.com डाल
दूंगा तो मैंने यहां पर netflix.com किया
एंटर किया मैं एंटर करूंगा इसका एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड यहां पर मुझे मिलेगा एंड इस
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड में आपको फाइंड करना है
कहीं कोई आईपी डिस्क्लोजर हो रही है क्या
कई बार हो जाती है आईपी डिस्क्लोजर कई बार
होती है कई बार नहीं होती है तो आपको
ट्राई आउट करना फाइंड करना है जब आपको यह
तीनों सडन वगैरह से नहीं मिले तो आप यह
वाला ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो तो मुझे यहां
पर कहीं कोई
आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर नहीं दिख रही है मेरे ख्याल
से
या यहां कुछ नहीं दिख रहा है सो नथिंग
हियर राइट नथिंग यर कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब
यहां पर मैं कता हूं
क्लास डज कॉ इस पर चलता हूं क्लास क इसका
देखता हूं एक बार एसएफ रिकॉर्ड देख लेता
हूं इनका सो यर वी गेट
द यह देखो एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड हमें मिला क्लास
डोजो का अब देखो तुम क्लास डोजो का आई तुम
देखोगे ना आईपी देखो पि h 4 क्लास do.com
तो जब तुम आईपी निकालो तो इसकी आईपी ये
वाली आ रही है 52
85 234 103 ये आईपी मिल रही है तुम्हें अब
इस आईपी को एक्सेस करके देखते हैं देखो
403 एरर आ रही है हमारे पास तो ये आईपी
क्या है 5285 वाली आईपी है अब मैं यहां पर
चलता हूं यहां पे 5285 कंट्रोल f करता हूं
5285 ये आईपी कहीं भी एजिस्ट नहीं करती है
जो यहां पे आपको दिख रही हो तो दीज आर
डिफरेंट आईपीस दैट वी आर गेटिंग इन द
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड तो आपको यहां पे एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड में यहां पे ये एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड
आपको यहां पे मिल रहा है इसमें कुछ
अलग-अलग आईपीस है तो यह आईपीस जो है ना
इनकी हो सकती है जो इनकी जैसे ए रिकॉर्ड
जैसे अब देखो एसएफ व ए रिकॉर्ड आपका जो है
आईपी वर्जन 4 का यह वाली है तो यह इनका
आईपी हो सकता है दिस कैन बी देयर अ ओन
रियल आईपी जो इनसे एसोसिएटेड हो सकता है
जिन पर आप अटैक्स वगैरह फरदर परफॉर्म कर
सकते हैं एंड जब रियल जो आईपी होती है
उसपे मैं एक बार एक बार आईपी कॉपी कर लेता
हूं एक बार लेट्स कॉपी द आईपी लेट्स ट्राई
टू ओपन इट कि क्या है ये ओपन करते हैं
देखते हैं व्हाट इज
दिस चलो एक वो आईपी है ये ओपन हमने करके
लगा
दिया ओके और भी आईपी है हम इनको भी ट्राई
करेंगे ओपन करने की वी विल ट्राई टू ओपन
दिस आईपी
आल्सो मल्टीपल आईपीस आर देयर 149 सीरीज का
भी एक आईपी उठा लेते हैं यहां से लेट्स
ट्राई टू ओपन दिस दिस वन मतलब दिस आईपीस
कैन बी एसोसिएटेड विद द रियल आईपीस ऑफ द
क्लास डोजो तो हम उस पे ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं राइट तो ये
अ अब इसम कोई इंपैक्टफुल
आप हां जी सॉरी
अब इसमें कुछ आप इंपैक्टफुल कुछ कर पा रहे
हैं व्हाट एवर तो आप यहां पे उनको रिपोर्ट
कर सकते हैं ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर अगर
हो रही है तो आप ट्राई कीजिए चेन अप करने
का जब आपको कुछ ऐसा मिलता है जब कोई लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट मिलती है तो आप उसको तुरंत
रिपोर्ट मत किया कीजिए मैं यही बोलूंगा कि
डोंट रिपोर्ट इन अ हरी आप ट्राई कीजिए
उसको और इंपैक्टफुल बनाने का जैसे ब्रोकन
लिंक हाईजैकिंग मिला मुझे तो आप प्रॉपर
इंपैक्ट के साथ दिखाइए जैसे गिट अप का पेज
है उसपे आप गिट अप का एक होस्ट कर दिया
आपने आपने वहां पे एक छोटा सा ऐप होस्ट कर
दिया मान लो सिंपल सा एंड आप फिर उससे
बहुत कुछ कर सकते हो राइट आपने कोई
[संगीत]
पोर्टस की जो वल्नरेबल पोर्ट्स आपको वहां
पर व मिल जा रहे हैं तो इस तरीके की चीज
आपको करनी चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से राइट अब इन
आईपी में से जैसे पहला आईपी तो हमारा यही
वाला है
ना तो इस आईपी को एक बार पिंग करके देख
लेते हैं लाइक इट इ पिंगबल और
नॉट जी हा देखिए यह पिंग हो रहा है मतलब य
आईपी एजिस्ट करती है दिस आईपी इ गेटिंग पि
आईपी एस्ट तो करती है तो अब इस पर आप क्या
कर सकते हैं इस आप एन मैप चला सकते हैं
राइट ट्राई ऑन ए मैप हियर ए मैप किया हमने
हान एवी लगा दिया एंड हमने इस आईपी प ए
मैप चला दिया अब आपको शायद कुछ डिफरेंट
रिजल्ट्स मिल जाए जिसके जो पिंग वाले आईपी
से मिल रहा था नॉर्मल उस उस आईपी को ना
करके हम इस आईपी पेन मैप चलाएंगे और हम
देखेंगे कि कहीं कुछ हमें कुछ मिल जाए यार
कुछ डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स कुछ पोर्ट्स
मिल जाए ओपन वी कैन ट्रा
राइट यस यस यस
यस
करेक्ट
तो यर वी हैव डन द एंड मैप थिंग लेट्स सी
कितना हुआ % अच्छा 7 पर हुआ ओनली ओके तो
काफी स्लो हो रहा है तो मैं इसको हान
टी 4 लगा देता हूं थोड़ा फास्ट हो जाएगा
शायद कितना हुआ
ओके इसको होने देते हैं इसको चलने देते
हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं या सो दिस वाज ओरिजनल आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर राइट तो आपको ये ट्राई आउट कर
देना इस तरीके से फाइंड आउट करना है चलिए
अब मैं यहां पर एक चीज दिखाता हूं
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड हार्ड
फेल चलिए यहां पर मैं एक चीज ओपन करता हूं
यहां
पे हां
जी
यस यस यस यू कैन से यू कैन
से बिल्कुल बिल्कुल आप बोल सकते हैं इफ यू
आर राइट कि अगर आपको सेम आईपी एड्रेस
मल्टीपल सोर्सेस से मिल रहे हैं तो आप
उसको बोल सकते हैं कि दिस इज
अ दिस इज काइंड ऑफ द आईपी ऑफ दैट
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट राइट तो आप बिल्कुल बोल
सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो यहां पे
हमारा कितना हुआ परसेंटेज देख लेते हैं एक
बार 28 पर हुआ अच्छी बात है सो लेट्स लेट
इट फिनिश तो फिर आप उस परे मल्टीपल काम कर
सकते हैं जो आप जनरली नहीं कर सकते दूसरे
प उस पर आप कर सकते हो
राइट ओके चलिए सो यर यर यर या या या टूल्स
फर
ह्यूमैनिटी ओके मैनेज है यहां
पे ओके होस्टिंगर होस्टिंगर भैया
होस्टिंगर भैया भी यहां पे होस्टिंगर कॉ
तो होस्टिंगर का भी अपन वैसे ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं लाइक पिंग i 4
h.com इसको ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं वी आर
गेटिंग दिस आईपी एंड आई थिंक दिस बिलोंग
टू क्लाउड फ्लेयर मेरे ख्याल से हां जी यह
क्लाउड फ्लेयर से ही बिलोंग करता है मुझे
समझ में आ गया था इसकी आईपी देख के तो
होस्टिंगर भी सेम चीज कर रही है क्लाउड
फलेर से तो हम होस्टिंगर भैया को भी एक
बार किटर मैन में डाल देंगे एक बार डालने
में किटर मैन में कोई वो नहीं है यहां पर
भी हम अपना य होस्टिंगर डाल देंगे सॉरी
होस्टिंग क क्या हमने डाला यहां पे एंड
यहां एंटर कर देते हैं लेट्स
सी हां तो यहां पे एक एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड मिल
गई है एंड ये देखो एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड मिली और
हमें एक आईपी मिल गई है भैया क्या बोलते
हो अब ये आईपी किसकी है ये थोड़ा सा
डिसाइड देखना पड़ेगा 312202
3.4 दिस आईपी वी आर गेटिंग दिस वन सो या
वी कैन ट्राई टू पिंग दिस आईपी फर्स्ट कि
आईपी एक्चुअली में काम कर रहा है कि नहीं
बिल्कुल ही काम कर रहा है लेट्स ओपन दिस
आईपी इन वेब इफ यू आर गेटिंग
समथिंग और ये अगर सेम डोमेन पे रीडायरेक्ट
हो जाता है तब तो यह पक्का से उसी का है
अगर यह होस्टिंगर खुल गया इस आईपी को ओपन
करने पे तब तो यह पक्का उसी का है बट अगर
नहीं भी खुलता है वी कैन ट्राई आउट वी कैन
फिगर इट आउट ट्राई करके हां कि हो सकता है
यहां पे आपका ये चीज काम कर रही हो ठीक है
सो ओके सो दिस वे यू कैन फाइंड दज रिकॉल्स
ओके तो यह आपको समझ में आई थिंक आ गया
होगा कि अ यह अ ओरिजिन आईपी डिस्क्लोजर जो
है आपका समझ में आ गया होगा लो हैंगिंग
फ्रूट्स फाइंड करने में अब इसी में मैंने
एक मिसिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड का भी आपको यहां
पे जिक्र किया था एंड यह आपको बताया था
मिसिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड क्या होता है अब
देखिए मिसिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड का मतलब होता
है एसपीएफ का मतलब होता है सेंडर्स पॉलिसी
फ्रेमवर्क ओके सेंडर्स पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क
का मतलब अब क्या होता है एसपीएफ का मतलब
क्या हो जाता है इज़ अ डीएनएस बेस रिकॉर्ड
दैट वेरीफाइज द मेल फ्रॉम और हेलो इको एक
जो भी अ हेलो या एचएलओ जो होती है
आइडेंटिटी आइडेंटिटी ड्यूरिंग मेल
ट्रांसमिशन इट सव्स एज अ पावरफुल टूल अगे
सेंडर्स एड एड्रेस फॉर जरी ठीक है मान लो
मान लो लेट्स सपोज कि मेरी टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर वेबसाइट है ठीक है मेरी वेबसाइट
है टेक्निकल नेविगेटर मान
लो ठीक है अब मेरी एक मेल आईडी है कौन सी
मेल आईडी है एडम @
technicalmastermind.com है मेरे टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर का एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड यहां पे
प्रेजेंट है अगर मैं टेक्निकल नेविगेटर को
सर्च करूंगा यहां पे गेट एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड
पे तो देयर इज एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड यहां पे
ऑलरेडी यहां पे लगा हुआ है तो यहां पे यह
सेफ है बट अगर यह नहीं होती ना एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड तो मैं क्या कर सकता था मतलब कोई
अटैकर क्या कर सकता था मेरे इस ईमेल से एक
फेक मेल कर सकता था किसी भी बंदे को और जब
वह करता एंड यहां पे सॉफ्ट फेल या हार्ड
फेल नहीं होता बेसिकली सॉफ्ट फेल या एनी
वन ऐसे कोई भी अलाउड होता अगर उसको करने
का मेल करने का मैं आपको बताऊंगा अभी तो
वो मेल उसके इनबॉक्स में भी जा सकती थी
एंड उसको लगता कि ये टेक्निकल नेविगेटर से
ऑफिशियल मेल आया है तो फिर वहां पे
प्रॉब्लेम हो जाता वो एंड वहां पे फिर
वहां मेरी फिर से अथॉरिटी मेरी फिर से
ऑथेंटिसिटी पे क्वेश्चन आ जाता एंड देयर
देयर आर मेनी थिंग्स मतलब वो क्रेडिबिलिटी
की कमी दिखाती है सिंपल जो भी आपका टारगेट
है उसके लिए ठीक है ये चीज होती है तो अब
ये एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड वाली चीज है यह बहुत
सारे जो प्रोग्राम से इसको आउट ऑफ स्कोप
रख देते हैं दे कंसीडर इट आउट ऑफ स्कोप दे
डोंट कंसीडर इट इन स्कोप आइटम तो आउट ऑफ
स्कोप आइटम्स रखते हैं बट कई बार अगर आप
इसका थोड़ा इंपैक्ट दिखा पाओ ना जैसे मास
मेल अटैक कर पाओ जैसे किसी कंपनी का आपने
वो देखो मैं आपको इसका दिखाता हूं कैसे ये
कर सकते हैं जैसे एक वेबसाइट है ईम के आईड
सीज देखते हैं काम करता है कि नहीं
ये हां तो जैसे मान लो ये वेबसाइट है ड सज
ठीक है तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा जैसे कि मैं
एक मेल ओपन कर लेता हूं लेट्स ओपन द मेल
लेट्स
वेट ओके लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट सो मैं यहां
पे मैं यहां पे कोई भी एक कंपनी ले लेते
हैं मैं य पर मेल आईडी ओपन कर लेता हूं एक
बार हां जी तो ये मैंने मेल आईडी एक ओपन
कर लिया राइट नाउ अब मान लो कोई एक ऐसी
वेबसाइट ढूंढते हैं जहां एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड
अवेलेबल नहीं है अब ये क्या होती है अभी
देखो एसपीएफ में क्या होता है मैं आपको एक
चीज बता देता हूं यहां पे एसपीएफ में यहां
पे होते हैं टू टाइप्स होते हैं बेसिकली
फेलर जो होते हैं एक सॉफ्ट फेल होता है एक
हार्ड फेल होता है ठीक है अब यहां पे
हार्ड फेल का मतलब क्या होता है हार्ड फेल
कैसे होता है जैसे एसपीएफ का जो रिकॉर्ड
होता है ना ये जो रिकॉर्ड है यहां पे
वर्जन पहला वर्जन हो गया इज इवल टू एपीएफ
वन हो गया
एमएक्क बबल है ए रिकॉर्ड जो आपकी होती है
डीएनएस में उसके लिए एप्लीकेबल है आईपी
वर्जन फोर के लिए है और लास्ट में यहां पे
ये कर्ली जो बक जो कर्ली आपका जो यहां पे
डैश है यहां पे एंड ऑल लिखा हुआ है तो दिस
एक्चुअली इज डिफरेंट टू टाइप्स ऑफ दिस यूज
टू बी देयर तो यहां पे एक ऐसे आता है और
एक ये हो सकती है कि यहां पे एक सिंपल डैश
ऑल हो दोनों में डिफरेंस है यहां पे ये
कर्ली डैश है यहां पे आपका इस तरीके से और
ये डायरेक्ट डैश है ठीक है तो अब यहां पर
देखो यहां पे देखो यह जो हार्ड फेल होता
है उसमें आपका यह डैश वाली चीज होगी डैश
वाली सिंपल सा एक हाइफ होगा एंड ऑल लिखा
होगा इसका मतलब क्या हो जाता माइनस
सिंबल मींस दैट एनी सेंडर नॉट लिस्टेड इन
दिस एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड शुड बी ट्रीटेड एज अ
हार्ड फेल दैट दे आर अनऑथराइज्ड एंड
ईमेल्स फ्रॉम देम शुड बी डिस्कार्डेड मतलब
जो भी अगर इस रिकॉर्ड में जो भी यहां पे
मेंशन नहीं है पर्टिकुलर जो भी मेंशन नहीं
है तो उसको ये ईमेल सेंड नहीं करने देगा
उस डोमेन के और उसको रिजेक्ट कर देगा
सिंपल सा इसका हाइ फन का मतलब वही है तो
अगर मेरे एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड में जैसे मेरे और
इसका मतलब क्या है सॉफ्ट फेल में कि देखो
यहां पे सॉफ्ट फेल है ये ब्रैकेट कर्ली
वाली जो डैश है वो है एंड यहां पे ऑल लिखा
हुआ है अब इसमें क्या है इन
द मींस दैट द सेंडर्स नॉट लिस्टिंग शुड बी
ट्रीटेड एज अ सॉफ्ट फेल दैट मेल कैन बी
अलाउड थ्रू बट शुड बी टैग्ड एज स्पैम और
सस्पिशंस पिशिर कैटेगरी में टैग कर दिया
जाएगा आपके जीमल के साइट से सिंपल सा फंडा
है तो ये चीज आपकी होती है और कई बार जब
ये दोनों नहीं होते हैं ना यह एजिस्ट नहीं
करते यह आपका इस तरह का कुछ लगा हुआ नहीं
है यहां पर सिंपल सा तो वह क्या होते हैं
मेल आपके चले जाते हैं जनरली कहां पे
इनबॉक्स में भी वो जा सकते हैं तो हम इसको
ट्राई आउट करेंगे अभी
देखिए जैसे मेरा तो यहां पर करली वाला लगा
हुआ है तो मेरा इनबॉक्स में नहीं जाएगा वो
या स्पैम में ट्रीट हो जाएगा
देखो तो कोई भी एक टारगेट ले लेते पहले
सो ओके टारगेट में हम यहां से कोई भी
टारगेट ले लेते
हैं चलो रैपिड का देख लेते हैं रैपिड का
कोई है क्या ऐसा कुछ
सीन रापिड नेट है id.com है ओजी है सब में
है तो मैं देख लेता हूं रनेट पहले देख
लेते हैं इसका एपफ रिकॉर्ड है कि नहीं है
अवेलेबल तो ओबवियसली इनका रिपो
हैड कॉ देख लेते हैं id.com
नहीं है तो id.com जो है इनका कोई एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड नहीं है सिंपल सा फंड है नो वैलिड
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड फाउंड ठीक है तो अब हम
क्या करते हैं id.com इसका एक फेक मेल
ट्राई करते करने का फ्रॉम नेम रैपिड
कस्टमर केयर फ्रॉम ईमेल तो मैं य पर कर
देता हूं हेलो
id.com टू मैं य पर अपने मेल प करता हूं
n13
सब्जेक्ट रिगार्डिंग
अकाउंट
क्लोजर ठीक
है हेलो
नितेश दिस इज बिली फ्रॉम रैपिड ऐसा एक फेक
मेल क्रिएट करते
हैं वी वुड लाइक टू इफॉर्म
यू दैट योर
अकाउंट माइट गेट क्लोज्ड इफ यू डिड नॉट इफ
यू डिड
नॉट अपडेट
योर अपडेट योर पासवर्ड ठीक है क्लिक यर टू
अपडेट ऐसे हमने लिंक डाला एक यहां पर एक
मलिस कोई लिंक ाल देगा कोई अटैकर एंड
सिंपल इस टाइप का मेल करके और ट्राई करेगा
मेल करने का तो यहां पर क्लिक ऑन द ल ए
सिमिलर टू द फॉलोइंग
सटी क्या है यटी यही है यही है दो लोग हैं
यहां पे सिलौटी ये रही ये रही ये
र अब यहां पे सेंड पे क्लिक कर देगा अब
जैसे सेंड पे क्लिक करेगा अगर मतलब कई बार
यह मेल आपके चले जाते हैं आपके मेल पे आ
जाते हैं ये मेल आपके डिलीवर हो जाएंगे
इनबॉक्स पे कई बार आ जाते हैं ठीक है कई
बार आपके नहीं भी आते हैं डिपेंड करता है
बट ये एक एसपीएफ मिसिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड का
ये एक एग्जांपल हो जाता है जैसे मैंने
यहां पे मैं यहां पे देखता हूं मेरे पास
आता है कि नहीं आता है लेट्स सी स्पैम में
भी देख लेते हैं बार शायद स्पैम में कहीं
कुछ मिल
जाए करेंटली इट्स नॉट हियर ओ नॉट हियर य
हैव टू से इट हां ईमेल स्पूफिंग जैसा ही
है कई बार कुछ टाइम लगता है आने में तो
आपको थोड़ा वेट भी करना पड़ सकता है कई
बार नहीं भी आए शायद मे बी बट ये यहां पे
आप इसका मास ईमेल अटैक यूज कर सकते हैं
लाइक एक बार में बहुत सारे ईमेल सेंड करके
एंड फ्लड कर देना ईमेल को किसी पर्टिकुलर
अगर वैसा कुछ भी कर पा रहे हैं आप देन दैट
इज परफेक्ट यू कैन ट्राई आउट बट मोस्टली
क्या हो जाता है यह जो वल एबिलिटी है ये
आउट ऑफ स्कोप में ही कंसीडर किया जाता है
यह बस आपके जानकारी के लिए मैंने आपको
बताया कि शायद आपका कभी ये यूज में आ जाए
ठीक है तो यहां पे आपका rapid.com जो है
यहां पे नो एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड है तो आप इस पे
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं मतलब कोई भी हैकर
जो है वो rapid.com के आगे कोई सा भी मेल
आईडी लगा के एंड उसको सेंड करने की कोशिश
कर सकता है ठीक है ट्राई आउट कर सकता है
बस इतना ही बोलूंगा चलो ये समझ में आ गया
ये था हमारा मिसिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड ये एक
वनबिल था अब
ओके सो दिस वाज मिसिंग दिस वाज ब्रोकन
लिंक मिसिंग एसपीएफ ओरिजिन आईपी
डिस्क्लोजर हमने डिस्कस कर लिया
एंड हां अब एसपीएफ वाली को थोड़ा सा
एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा यह जब रहे तो सॉफ्ट फेल है यह हार्ड
फेल है यह जब रहेगा तो मेल में आ जाएगी बट
यह स्पैम की तरह ट्रीट हो जाएगा यह होगा
तो बिल्कुल भी नहीं आएगा ठीक है ना अगर
नहीं होगा तो फिर तो कोई बात ही नहीं है
ठीक है राइट तो ये आप ट्राई कर लीजिएगा अब
एक और चीज है हमारा सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
आफ्टर लॉग आउट अब ये भी बहुत सारी जो आपकी
प्रोग्राम्स है बग बाउटी के उसमें नॉट
एप्लीकेबल में आ जाता है या फिर आउट ऑफ
स्कोप आता है बट बहुत सारे में स्कोप में
ये रहेगा छोटे मोटे प्रोग्राम्स में आप
ट्राई आउट कीजिएगा वहां पे ये मिल जाएगा
सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग आफ्टर लॉग आउट में
क्या हो जाता है सिंपल सा फंडा है एक ही
अकाउंट में जैसे आपने क्या किया सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग में क्या हो जाता है
देखो जैसे मैंने
में फिर से
कैटेगरी में आ जाता है सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग आफ्टर लॉग आउट में एंड
बेसिकली आप
इसको
सॉरी इसको आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं यू कैन
जस्ट रिपोर्ट दिस लेबिलिटी एंड अगर वो
कंसीडर कर लेते हैं देन दे विल डेफिनेटली
रिवर्ड यू बट बहुत छोटी सी बाउंट या
रिवर्ड आपको मिल जाती है इसके अंदर में
बहुत ज्यादा बाउंट एक्सपेक्ट आप मत
कीजिएगा क्योंकि ये बहुत ही लो लेवल के
वनरे एबिलिटीज है तभी इनका नाम है लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स सिंपल सा फंड है तो मतलब
कोई से भी आप कोई सा भी अपने टारगेट प दो
अकाउंट कट मतलब एक अकाउंट एक ब्राउजर में
एक अकाउंट लॉगिन कर ली सेम अकाउंट को
दूसरे ब्राउजर में लॉगइन कर लीजिए और उसका
पासवर्ड चेंज करके देख लीजिए सिंपल सा
फंडा है और कुछ भी नहीं है जैसे मैं यहां
पर कोई सा भी चल देता हूं रैपिड वगैरह में
कहीं प भी चल
दो
यहां पर कुछ लॉगइन का कुछ है क्या सीन
रैपिड में देख लेते
हैं
ओज यहां पे साइन अप लॉगिन का है यहां पे
साइन अप कर लेता हूं मैं यहां पे एक बार
देखते हैं साइन अप में क्या सिस्टम है
बहुत लंबा सा सिस्टम है साइन अप में ओ माय
गॉड लंबा सिस्टम है तो मैं क्या कर लेता
हूं यहां पर नितेश
सि कंट्री में इंडिया डाल देता हूं ओ माय
गॉड कंट्री में इंडिया है ही नहीं वाओ देख
लो कंट्री में दे हैव नॉट पुट कंट्री में
इंडिया तो ऐसे इसको मैं साइड कर देता हूं
यह फालतू प्रोग्राम है इंडिया का नाम नहीं
दिया इन्होने यह तो बेकार चीज कर चलो कोई
और टारगेट ले लेते हैं एक और टारगेट जस्ट
टेकन कोई और
जैसे ऑर्डर गिफ्ट ऐसे सर्च कर लेते कुछ भी
रैंडम
वेबसाइट ए
ए पड कॉ चलो विनी ड इन चलो विनी प ही आ
जाते हैं विनी
प यहां पर एक साइन अप कर लेते
हैं
ओके साइन अप कर लिया हमने एंड साइन अप में
य पर क्या आ रहा है भैया ईमेल आईडी या
मोबाइल नंबर तो
मैं लॉग इन विथ ग क्या कर सकते हैं लगन
में चलिए देखते हैं य पर तो लॉग इन विथ ग
में चलते हैं दूसरे वाले प यहां पर कौन सी
ग अकाउंट लॉगइन है भाई देख लेते हैं ये
वाली सेम लॉगिन है क्या इधर मैक्न वाली
लॉगिन है चलिए मटसन से हम लॉगइन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे मैक्सन सलूशन इससे लॉगइन कर
लेते हैं ग
से
कंटिन्यू देखते हैं पासवर्ड चेंज करने का
ऑप्शन है क्या कहीं प यहां
पे माय
अकाउंट क्या हुआ
भाई व्ट इज दिस ओके यहां पे लॉगइन हो गया
मे सलूशन टाइटल मेक्स यहां पे फोन नंबर
मांग रहे हैं ये तो फोन नंबर दे देता हूं
मैं फोन नंबर दे दिया मैंने यहां प
कंटिन्यू करते हैं य शायद ये ओटीपी
मांगेंगे हा
जी तो ओटीपी देते
हैं
034 तो हमने ओटीपी दे दिया नाउ वी आर
गेटिंग लॉग इन तो लॉग इन हो चुके हैं हम
यहां पे अब अकाउंट प चलते हैं एंड एंड एंड
एंड कुछ है क्या अकाउंट में कुछ जो हम
चेंज कर सकते हैं कुछ है ही नहीं शायद
यार अकाउंट की कॉन्फिन के कुछ सिस्टम ही
नहीं समझ में आ रहा मुझे तो यह
रहा पासवर्ड का कुछ सिस्टम पासवर्ड सिस्टम
पासवर्ड लेस हो चुके हैं यार बहुत सारी
चीजें यह आजकल के टाइम
में ओके कुछ नहीं है यहां पे पासवर्ड
चेंजिंग का तो इस पर हम नहीं जाते हैं एफ
एनपी प चल देते हैं एफ एनपी फन एंड पेटल्स
पे तो एफ एनपी प चलते हैं देखते हैं यहां
पे क्या सिस्टम है गेस्ट चलते हैं लॉगइन
रजिस्टर प चलते हैं आई होप यहां पर तो सही
होगा कुछ रजिस्टर प करते हैं हां ठीक है
रजिस्टर आ गया य पे
तो ईमेल आईडी दे देते हैं
मेव
सलूशन
gmail.com
कंटिन्यू नेम नितेश मोबाइल नंबर मांग रहे
हैं दे दिया कंटिन्यू ओटीपी अगेन तो तो
आना ही है यार ओटीपी कैसे नहीं आएगा भाई आ
जाओ ओटीपी आ
जाओ ओके 1092
वेरीफाई क्रिएट पासवर्ड वाह ये अच्छी बात
है यार पासवर्ड क्रिएट करना है तो मैं
यहां प पासवर्ड एक बार डाल देता
हूं मैंने पासवर्ड डाल दिया यहां पे एंड
यहां पर मैंने इसको कंटिन्यू कर दिया ठीक
है भैया कंटिन्यू चलिए तो हम यहां पे
अकाउंट क्रिएट बन अकाउंट क्रिएट हो चुकी
है अब मैं सेम अकाउंट एफ एफ एप का
facebook.com एंटर किया पासवर्ड डाला
मैंने यहां पे जो मैंने पासवर्ड वहां पे
लॉगिन किया था सिंपल मैंने यहां पे
कंटिन्यू कर दिया अब मैंने यहां पे दोनों
जगह पे लॉगइन कर लिया अब मैं अपने
अकाउंट पे चलते हैं अ चेंज पासवर्ड प
क्लिक करते हैं एंड यहां पे ओटीपी एक आएगा
आपके नंबर पे फिर से तो ओटीपी डालते हैं
अगेन 1092 आया क्या यार नहीं नहीं 5577
5577 ये मैंने किया वेरीफाई कर दिया उसके
बाद न्यू पासवर्ड अब मैं यहां पे एक नया
पासवर्ड क्रिएट करता हूं तो मैं यहां
पे नया पासवर्ड मैंने क्रिएट किया पहले
पासवर्ड से डिफरेंट है ये ठीक है मैंने
क्रिएट किया सेव किया एंड पासवर्ड चेंज
सक्सेसफुली पासवर्ड चेंज हो चुका अब अब
मैं यहां पे कम यहां पे चलता हूं
firefox.exe
और नॉट दैट इज अ डिफरेंट थिंग बट सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग आफ्टर लॉग आउट तो मैंने लॉग
आउट किया भी फिर भी हां मैं अब क्या करता
हूं
ना मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं मैंने
पासवर्ड चेंज कर दिया सब कुछ चेंज कर दिया
अब मैं यहां प आके लॉग आउट भी कर देता हूं
मैंने कम पे आया मैं कम पे आया मैं यहां
पे लॉग आउट कर देता हूं पासवर्ड चेंज किया
मैंने लॉग आउट कर देता हूं लेट लेट्स लॉग
आउट ठीक है पासवर्ड चेंज किया लॉग आउट कर
दिया कम यहां प firefox.exe
ली द सेशन रिमेंस सेन मतलब यहां पे ये
अकाउंट लॉगिन रह रहा है पासवर्ड चेंज करने
के बाद भी हमारा अकाउंट जो है वो प्रीवियस
उस तरीके से लॉग आउट रह रहा है तो कुछ
नहीं है बस सिंपल सा फंडा है यहां पे ये
वल्नरेबल है आप चाहे तो रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हैं लाइक इसमें कुछ है क्या रिपोर्ट करने
का आई डोंट थिंक इसमें कोई रिपोर्ट का
होगा कुछ यहां पे इनका बर्क बाउंडी
प्रोग्राम कुछ तो नहीं होगा
शायद या नॉट एनी बक बाटी प्रोग्राम बट या
आप चाहे तो रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं इफ यू
वांट यू कैन रिपोर्ट इट टू देम ये डिपेंड
करता है उनके पे कि वो कुछ इसको एक्सेप्ट
करेंगे कि नहीं करेंगे राइट दिस डिपेंड्स
टोटली अपन देम तो एफ एनपी का बक बाउंट
प्रोग्राम शायद नहीं होगा एफ एन पी बग
बाउंट या है देख लेते
[संगीत]
हैं ओके ओपन बग बाउंट पर इनका
है
ओके लेट्स
सी ओके सो य
एफएनपी आई थिंक है तो यहां पर इन्होंने
लाइक एक्सस रिपोर्ट किया था इनको तो
इन्होने एक्सेस ओके चलिए अच्छी बात है य प
तो यू कैन बेसिकली रिपोर्ट देम अगर आपको
चाहिए रिपोर्ट करने का तो आप रिपोर्ट कर
सकते हैं अगर यह एक्सेप्ट करते हैं तो ठीक
है रिपोर्ट में सिंपल सा आपको यह लिखना है
कि देयर
इज देर इ सेशन यहां पर आपको यह वाली चीज
लिखनी है सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
आफ्टर लॉग आउट इस तरीके का आपको चेंज कर
आपको वो कर देना है आफ्टर पासवर्ड चेंज
लॉग आउट जो भी आप डिटेल में पूरा लिखिए
ठीक है किंड देन स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस
में आप जाके वहां पे आप लिखिए कि आई मेड
टू अकाउंट्स वन अ विक्टिम अकाउंट वन अटैकर
अकाउंट आई लॉग इन विद द सेम अकाउंट बोथ
साइड एंड देन मैंने एक अकाउंट का पासवर्ड
चेंज किया एक ब्राउजर में एंड उसको लॉग
आउट भी कर दिया बट दूसरे अकाउंट जो है वो
ना तो लॉग आउट हुआ ना ही वो सेशन हमारा
टर्मिनेट हुआ एंड हम आराम से उसमें उस
पर्टिकुलर अकाउंट को यूज कर सकते हैं इवन
आफ्टर चेंजिंग द पासवर्ड बट बाय डिफॉल्ट
होना ये चाहिए कि अगर पासवर्ड चेंज हुआ है
तो वो लॉक आउट हो जाना चाहिए सिक्योरिटी
मैकेनिज्म के अकॉर्डिंग सेम इस तरह का
फंडा ही होना चाहिए जनरिक एक सिक्योरिटी
मैकेनिज्म है ये तो ये ज्यादा बेटर होती
है मेरे ख्याल से एंड दिस शुड बी देयर फॉर
एनी प्रोग्राम्स ठीक है तो आपको ये चीज
उनको बताना है ठीक है कि मैंने एक वेबसाइट
पे यहां पे एक कम पे एक ब्राउजर में मैंने
यहां पे लॉग इन किया था एंड यहां पे मैंने
पासवर्ड चेंज किया ब्राउजर में मैंने इसको
रीलोड किया अगेन आई कैन स्टिल एक्सेस दैट
सेम अकाउंट विदाउट गेटिंग लगड आउट सो देयर
इज लाइक सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग इवन आफ्टर
लॉग आउट एंड पास चेंज तो ये चीज आप मेंशन
करके आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं इस तरह की
चीजों को छोटी-मोटी चीजें हैं बट कभी-कभी
50 100 की बाउंट लग जाती है इसके कोई कोई
अगर वो एक्सेप्ट कर लेते हैं तो दे कैन
गिव यू 50 टू 100 छोटे मोटे अमाउंट जो है
वो 000 या 4 5000 वो दे सकते है आपको ठीक
है चलिए तो यह था से नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
आफ्टर लॉग आउट इस तरीके या आफ्टर पासवर्ड
चेंज इस तरीके का चीज आप डाल सकते हैं या
आफ्टर टू एए मतलब आपने एक एक अकाउंट में
क्या किया टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑन कर
लिया पासवर्ड चेंज कर लिया एंड देन भी आप
सेकंड अकाउंट एक्सेस कर पा रहे हो वो भी
इसके अंदर आ जाता है ठीक है तो ये चीज हो
गई अब हमारा एक लास्ट वाला जो बचा हुआ है
वो है लॉन्ग पासवड डॉस अटैक दिस लेबिलिटी
इज अ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग लेबिलिटी ये हम इसी
पे ट्राई आउट कर लेंगे एफएनपी पे अब लॉन्ग
पासवर्ड ड अटैक में क्या होता है मैं आपको
बता देता हूं जसे एक पासवर्ड की इतनी लंबी
स्ट्रिंग्स डालना कि उससे आपकी वेबसाइट जो
है अनरिस्पांसिव हो जाए या वेबसाइट प
इनडायरेक्टली आप यू कहे एक डॉस अटैक टाइप
हो जाए तो वो एक लॉन्ग पासवर्ड डॉस अटैक
कहलाता है अब जैसे मान लो मैंने अकाउंट
क्रिएट किया था अभी इस पर ठीक है अब मैं
एक काम करता हूं मैं फिर से एक अकाउंट
क्रिएट कर लेता हूं मैं य लॉगिन रजिस्टर
पर जाता
हूं मैं यहां पर इसके लिए बॉब शूट को ओपन
करूंगा सो आई नीड बॉब शूट सो लेट्स ओपन
बॉब
शूट ओके मजा आ रहा है समझ में आ रहा है ना
भाई एवरीवन गेटिंग गेटिंग टू
अंडरस्टैंड
चलिए नेक्स्ट करता हूं मैं स्टार्ट करता
हूं प्रॉक्सी इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देता हूं
मैं यहां पे मैं यहां पे बॉब शूट का यह ऑन
कर लेता हूं यहां प बॉब
ओके
चलिए अब देखिए यहां पे मैं लॉगइन रजिस्टर
प यहां पर एक नया अकाउंट क्रिएट करूंगा
सिंपल सा एंड नया अकाउंट क्रिएट करने के
लिए मैं ईमेल आईडी डालता हूं तो मैं ईमेल
आईडी में टप मेल अब इस बार यूज कर लेता
हूं मैं अपनी ईमेल आईडी कितना यूज करूंगा
सो लेट्स यूज टेंप
मेल आई गट सम बाउंटीज फ्रॉम लॉन्ग पास डस
अटैक ग्रेट अच्छी बात
है सो यहां पे मैंने एक ईमेल आईडी ले लिया
ये वाली और मैं यहां पर एक ईमेल आईडी
डालूंगा कंटिन्यू पर क्लिक करूंगा नेम
डालूंगा राहुल
मोबाइल नंबर मैं
डालूंगा आई थिंक यह मोबाइल नंबर वापस लेगा
कि नहीं पता नहीं कंटिन्यू करता
हूं अगेन सेम मोबाइल नंबर ओटीपी
आएगा मैंने कर दिया वेरीफाई कर देते हैं य
प अब य प एक पासवर्ड क्रिएट करने का ऑप्शन
आरहा है देखो जब यह पासवर्ड क्रिएट करने
का ऑप्शन आ रहा है तो यहां पर हम एक
पासवर्ड कोई सा भी डालते हैं ठीक है कोई
सा भी एक पासवर्ड डालते हैं चलिए तो अब य
पर पासवर्ड डालते हैं अल्फा न्यूमेरिक
पासवर्ड होना चाहिए तो ए बी सी डी टूथ 4 5
ये पासवर्ड डाला हमने ए बी सीडी टूथ 4 5
अब इसको आगे बढ़ाने से पहले बब शूट में
इसको इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे मैंने यहां पर
कंटिन्यू प क्लिक किया उसके पहले मैं इसको
इंटरसेप्ट करता हूं बब शूट के अंदर में
ठीक है सो आईम जस्ट इंटरसेप्टिंग इट
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं एफ एनपी में आ गया य पे
यहां पे आपको देखो पासवर्ड में पासवर्ड
कहीं दिख रहा है यहां प पास पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड वे इ द
पासवर्ड
ट्रू ए बी सी अच्छा ये पासवर्ड नहीं है
यहां पे फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं कहां गई भाई पासवर्ड
भाई वेर इज द पासवर्ड फीड
यार व्हाट इज
दिस
अ स्पेशल कैरेक्टर भी होना
चाहिए तो टट भी लगा देते य पर इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑन कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स नाउ ड थ तो
मैं य पर फॉरवर्ड करता हूं फॉरवर्ड करता
हूं फॉरवर्ड करता हूं फॉरवर्ड करता हूं
फॉरवर्ड करता हूं यह रहा तो यहां पर
पासवर्ड तो आ जाना चाहिए ए बी सी
डी कहां गई पासवर्ड यार पासवर्ड क्यों
नहीं दिख रहा
मुझे फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते एक बार लेट्स डू
वन
थिंग लेट्स गो टू लेट्स इसको क्लोज करते
हैं डि अरे यार क्या हो रहा है ये इसको तो
किया था ना हमने चलो इसको डिसेबल कर देते
हैं य पर फिलहाल के लिए इसको हटा देते हैं
इस पर चलते हैं फर फॉक्स प चलते हैं लेट्स
इनेबल बब शूट एंड इसको लॉग आउट कर देते
हैं फिलहाल के
लिए ठीक है लॉग आउट कर दिया
हमने
नाउ सभी को बंद कर देते हैं यहां
पे जितनी भी चीज उसको बंद करो यहां प चलते
हैं गेस्ट प लॉग इन रजिस्टर प चलते हैं
यहां पर टेंप
मेल ओपन करते
हैं ओके ईमेल आईडी देते यहां
पर
कंटिन्यू ओके नेम में राहुल देते हैं
मोबाइल नंबर में मैं सेम
दे ठीक है ईमेल आईडी दी हुई है तो य पर
अगेन मुझे वेरीफाई करना पड़ जाएगा मोबाइल
नंबर लेट म
वेरीफाई
96 ओके वेरीफाई कर देता हूं य पासवर्ड आ
रहा है तो पास ए बी सी थ 45 एंड
[संगीत]
लेट्स इंटरसेप्ट
इट कंटिन्यू पे करता हूं मैं कंटिन्यू पे
किया मैंने यहां पे एफएनपी आ गया यहां पे
अब यहां पासवर्ड देखते हैं यहां पे
पासवर्ड मिल भी रही है कि नहीं मुझे यार
पासवर्ड ए बी सी कुछ पासवर्ड यहां है नहीं
आर नहीं दि
यार ओके
फॉरवर्ड अ फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड ओके सो आई थिंक पासवर्ड इज गेटिंग
इनकोडेड हियर सो ट्स व वी आर नॉट सीइंग
राइट बट कोई बात नहीं
है
चलेगा ओके यह
रहा
रिस्पांस इसका एक बार देख लेते हैं क्या
रिस्पांस आ रहा है इसका ओके य एरर वाइल
साइनिंग अप कांटेक्ट ओके सो कुछ साइनिंग
अप एरर आ रही है चलिए इसको हम बंद कर देते
हैं चलिए कोई और एक वेबसाइट ले लेते हैं
गिफ्ट
ऑर्डर आईजीपी कॉ ये है इस पर चल जाते हैं
इनक्रेडिबल गिफ्ट्स इस पर चल जाते हैं
जीवा को इस पर चल जाते हैं फ्लर और और इस
चल देते हैं तो यह भी चीज है सो लेट्स गो
हियर साइन अप करते हैं एंड हां यहां पर
साइन अप हो रहा है य प आपके आईजीपी पे तो
मैं यहां पर नेम नितेश डाल देता हूं ईमेल
आईडी मैं यहां
पे वही फेक ईमेल आईडी डाल देता हूं तो यह
किस पर ओपन हो रही है भैया फ फॉक्स ओपन कर
लेते
इसको लेट्स ओपन इट ऑन
फायरफॉक्स सेम ईमेल आईडी का यूज करेंगे हम
यहां पर एंड यहां पर वी आर गोइंग टू साइन
अप
नितेश ईमेल आईडी डाल देते हैं य पर
पासवर्ड डाल देते हैं अब य पासवर्ड में
वही चीज डालता ए बी सी
टूथ
सॉरी ए बी सी टट यह डालते हैं मोबाइल नंबर
में य डाल देते
हैं ठीक है डेट ऑफ बर्थ में य पर डाल देता
हूं ठीक है चलिए य हटा देते हैं यहां
पे नो लवेज ब्लॉक तो ए बीसी ट ये हमने
डाला यहां पर पासवर्ड अब हम यहां पर क्या
करते हैं इसको इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर लेते
हैं एंड लेट्स साइन अप ठीक है साइन अप पर
क्लिक किया हमने यहां प अब यहां पर चलते
हैं ओके कंट्री चूज करना पड़ेगा हम तो
कंट्री हम चूज कर लेते हैं
इंडिया साइन अप पर क्लिक करते
हैं एंड लेट्स गो हियर लेट्स फॉरवर्ड एंड
यह चीज आ चुकी है कौन सी आईजीपी प तो यहां
पे हमारा ए बी सी नथिंग हियर फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं अ फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ओके इफ
यू गेट द पासवर्ड
हियर नथिंग फॉरवर्ड हां ये रहा हां जी तो
अब हमें रिक्वेस्ट मिल चुकी है ये वाली
सिंपल अब यहां पे आपको पासवर्ड दिख रहा है
ये ये पासवर्ड दिख रहा है ए bc1 2 3 @ और
यहां पे हमने ये वाली पासवर्ड ही डाली
abc1 23 @ @ और यहां पे हमने इस रिक्वेस्ट
को कैप्चर किया अब यहां पे हम इसको बड़ा
बनाएंगे इस पासवर्ड को ठीक है अब इसको
लॉन्ग स्ट्रिंग पासवर्ड मैंने इस पासवर्ड
को कॉपी किया मैं यहां पर भी सेम डाला सेम
डाला अब मैं यहां पर इसको डालते जाऊंगा इस
तरीके से इसको बड़ा बना दूंगा ठीक
है मैंने यहां बड़ा बनाया अब मैं इस पूरे
को कॉपी कर लेता हूं एक
बार सॉरी मैं क्या कर देता हूं इस पूरे को
ही कॉपी कर लेता हूं तो मैं यहां पर पूरे
ही इस पासवर्ड को कॉपी कर लेता हूं यहां
से ए बी सी से कॉपी भी
किया मैंने एक बहुत लंबा स्ट्रिंग का यहां
पे पासवर्ड जनरेट किया बहुत ही लॉन्ग
स्ट्रिंग का ये देखो इतना लंबा यहां पे
स्ट्रिंग डाल दिया ये पासवर्ड का ये कुछ
ज्यादा ही लंबा स्ट्रिंग हो गया देखते हैं
एंड अगर यह मुझे साइन अप अलाउ कर देता है
इतने लंबे स्ट्रिंग के बाद इस तरीके से
साइन अप फिर भी कर देता है यहां पे तो हो
सकता है ये वेब एप्लीकेशन जो है वो
रिस्पांसिस ना रहे अनरिस्पांसिव हो जाए
ऐसा भी हो सकता है या तो कोई अगर
रिस्ट्रिक्शन होगी किसी तरह का कोई अ एक
रिस्ट्रिक्शन लगा होगा किसी तरह की कोई
सिक्योरिटी काम कर रही है वहां पे फिर यह
नहीं करेगा हमें वो पर्टिकुलर हमें अकाउंट
क्रिएट नहीं करने देगा ठीक है तो मैं अब
क्या करता हूं यहां पे सिंपल सा फॉरवर्ड
करके इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देता हूं लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग हियर सो हमने फॉरवर्ड
करके यहां पे किया एंड देखते हैं क्या हो
रहा
है सो करेंटली वीी आर लॉग इन तो हम यहां
पे लॉग इन एक्चुअली हो चुके हैं एक्चुअली
वीी आर लॉग इन विद दैट पर्टिकुलर वहां पे
तो यहां पे ये वेरीफाई तो नहीं हो रहा है
बट यहां हमारी वेबसाइट कोई डाउन या कुछ
अनरिस्पांसिव टाइप भी कुछ हुई नहीं है
शायद मैं यहां पे रीलोड कर लेता हूं यहां
पे या अ नॉट लाइक दैट कुछ ज्यादा कुछ खास
यहां पे असर यहां पे पड़ा नहीं है वेबसाइट
के ऊपर यहां पे हमारे पास कुछ आया नहीं है
अगर यहां पे ये चीज आई रहती यहां पे
वेबसाइट अनरिस्पांसिव हो जाती तो फिर
दिक्कत थी फिर यहां पे फिर यहां पे ये
लॉन्ग पासवर्ड डॉस अटैक हो जाता तो ऐसा ही
आपको करना है एक टारगेट चूज करना है जब भी
आप पासवर्ड क्रिएट करते हैं या लॉग इन
करने जाते हैं आप लॉगइन करने के टाइम में
भी चेक आउट चेक चेक कर सकते हैं ठीक है आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं लॉगिन करने जैसे
मैं यहां पे साइन साइन आउट कर देता
हूं ठीक है मैं यहां पे लॉग इन करने जाता
हूं ठीक है तो मैंने यहां पे ईमेल डाला
यहां पे जो मेरा ईमेल था ये ये वाली ईमेल
यह डाल दी और मैं यहां पे पासवर्ड में
फिलहाल के लिए कुछ भी डाल देता हूं लाइक
व्हाट एवर रैंडम पासवर्ड यहां पे एंड मैं
यहां पे साइन इन करने से पहले इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑन कर लूंगा ठीक है साइन इन करने से
पहले इंटरसेप्ट ऑन किया मैं यहां प
फॉरवर्ड करूंगा एंड यहां पे देखूंगा मैं
यहां पे पासवर्ड य ये वाली पासवर्ड आ रही
है तो मैं इसको रैंडम कुछ पासवर्ड्स डाल
के यहां पे एक बार ट्राई ये तो मैंने
रैंडम बस बता रहा हूं मैं आपको आईडिया दे
रहा हूं तो आप सेम पासवर्ड डालिए तो यहां
पे मैंने एकदम रैंडम स्ट्रिंग बना दिया
पासवर्ड का एंड मैं ट्राई करूंगा इसे
लॉगइन करने का एंड लेट्स सी एंड वी विल सी
लाइक व्हाट इज द रिजल्ट वी आर एक्चुअली
गेटिंग बस सिंपल सा फंडा है इसको आप
रिक्वेस्ट को भेज देते सेंड टू रिपीटर को
भेज के आप देख सकते हैं डायरेक्टली तो
फिलहाल के लिए आप इसको इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर
दीजिए रिपीटर में चलते हैं यहां पे रिपीटर
में आप चलेंगे यहां पे तो यहां पे हमरे को
हमारे को बहुत लंबा एक स्ट्रिंग मिल चुका
है तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि
रिस्पांस क्या आ रहा है आपका तो मैंने
यहां पे ये लंबा सा पासवर्ड स्ट्रिंग दे
दिया मैं इसको गो पे क्लिक करूंगा तो वी
कैन गेट द 200 यहां पे ये 200 ओके का यहां
पे आ रहा है स्टेटस सक्सेस होके यहां पे आ
रहा है यहां पे एंड प्लीज एंटर द वैलिड
ईमेल आईडी पासवर्ड ये आ रही है बट यहां पे
क्या हो रहा है कि कोई ऐसा कुछ हमारा डाउन
नहीं हो रहा है वेबसाइट हमारी 200 ओके ही
आ रही है तो ये परफेक्ट है ये हमारा
वल्नरेबल नहीं है काइंड ऑफ इस तरीके से
ठीक है तो इस तरीके से ये चीज काम करती है
लॉन्ग पासवर्ड अगर ये वल्नरेबल होगी तो
यहां पे आपका पेज जो है वो सर्वर इशू
सर्वर एरर 5x वाली एरर जो होगी फाइव अ एक्
वाली जो भी एरर्स आती हैं फाइव से
स्टार्टिंग जो आपकी आपने देखा होगा
एचटीटीपी स्टेटस कोर्स जो पढ़ा होगा आपने
तो वो वाली कुछ भी आपको यहां पे नंबर आ
सकती है अनरिस्पांसिव का या कुछ भी व्हाट
एवर तो आप समझ जाइएगा कि वहां पे दिक्कत
है और वेबसाइट भी हो सकता है आपकी वो काम
करनी बंद कर दे तो ये भी आप चेक आउट कर
लीजिए तो ये हो गया लॉन्ग पास टैक
छोटी-मोटी वेबसाइट्स पे ज्यादातर काम करती
है मोस्टली आपकी काम कर सकती है जैसे
इनक्रेडिबल गिफ तो आप इस पर भी ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं ये छोटी वेबसाइट ही लग रही है
इट कैन नॉट बी अ वेरी बिग वेबसाइट तो यू
कैन ट्राई आउट न हियर ठीक है तो आप इस पे
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो सेम अगेन यहां पे
रजिस्टर कर दीजिए यहां पे ईमेल पासवर्ड
मांग रहा है अगेन तो मैंने यहां पे एक
ईमेल डाल दिया फेक
ईमेल चलिए मैं यहां डाल देता हूं फेक ईमेल
एक डाल देता
हूं
प्रॉक्सी
चलते क्या आ रहा है 500 इंटरनल सर्वर एरर
आ गया किस पर आ गया भाई इंटरनल सर्वर एरर
य बताओ यार वो अगर आ रहा है तो सही है फिर
रिपोर्ट कर सकते हो इंटरनल सर्वर कुछ आ
रहा है तो कर सकते
हो किसका आ रहा है इंटरनल सर्वर यह बताओ
जरा रजिस्टर पर क्लिक करते हैं ईमेल आडस
डाल देते हैं
सॉरी ईमेल एड्रेस यहां से उठा लेते हैं
यहां डाल देते हैं पासवर्ड य डाल दे
ए बी सी टव 23 4 5 ये हमने डाल
दिया अरे भाई ए बी सी डॉट डॉट
थ ये हमने डाल दिया चलिए ए बी सी डॉट डड
जो भी है यहां पे तो यहां पे हम करके यहां
पे रजिस्टर इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर लेते हैं एंड
इसको हम रजिस्टर पर क्लिक करते हैं ये
हमारे यहां प आ चुका होगा यहां पे ए बी सी
डॉट डॉट डॉट ये वाली अब चीज आ गई पासवर्ड
में इसको हम राइट क्लिक करते हैं रिपीटर
को सेंड कर देते हैं ठीक है तो हमने तो ये
सिंपल सा फंडा किया य सिंपल सा फंडा य यूज
किया ब इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं सेम चीज
को यहां
से कॉपी करता
हूं पेस्ट कर देता हूं यहां
पर पेस्ट करता हूं मैं यहां पर पेस्ट कर
देता हूं अब मैं इस पूरे को ही कॉपी कर
लेता
हूं पूरे को ही कॉपी किया मैंने यहां
पेस्ट
किया तो यहां पर मैंने पासवर्ड की लंबी सी
स्ट्रिंग बना दी पूरी
ठीक है लेट्स मेक लंग स्ट्रिंग ये देखो
बहुत लंबी स्ट्रिंग बना
दी ठीक है बना दिया मैंने अब यहां प य पर
फॉरवर्ड करेंगे इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देंगे
एंड देखेंगे य पर क्या हो रहा है लेट्स सी
व्ट इ
हैपनिंग कुछ लोडिंग लोडिंग थोड़ा सा तो
लोडिंग हुआ था बट ठीक है मतलब इस तरीके से
आप कर सकते हो जैसे मैं रिपीटर प आता हूं
य पे एंड यहां पे जो चीज
थी वी वी वी वी एंड उसके बाद इसको मैं
पूरा कॉपी कर लेता हूं यहां से यहां तक
कंट्रोल सी अब मैं कंट्रोल व करके यहां पे
एक लॉन्ग स्ट्रिंग बना देता हूं और
रिस्पांस देख लेंगे ना क्या रिस्पांस आ
रहा
है सो लेट्स आप इतना कितने भी स्ट्रिंग
डाल सकते हैं वो आपकी मर्जी है व्हाट एवर
स्ट्रिंग यू वांट यू कैन जस्ट एक्सपोर्ट
इट आउट
हियर मजा आ रहा है देख के चलिए तो ये यहां
पे हो रहा है अ
दैट्ची
ये फाइन है थोड़े और यहां पर ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं थोड़े और यहां पे देखें कुछ और
भी यहां प लगा के दे ट्राई कर सकते हैं वी
कन ट्राई इट आउट कुछ रिजल्ट डिफरेंट मिलता
है
क्या हम गो प क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग अगेन ओके अगेन 200 ओके
तो हैंडलिंग इ इट इज हैंडलिंग सो इट्स नॉट
वल्नरेबल काइंड ऑफ नॉट वल्नरेबल ऐसा तो
आपको ऐसा ट्राई करना है ठीक है इस तरीके
से ट्राई करना है अगर वो
अ डाउन हो जाती है वेबसाइट या किसी तरीके
से अनरिस्पांसिव हो जाती है या आपको यहां
पे अ रिस्पांस में आपके यहां पे कुछ 500
वाली 500x वाली आपको रिस्पांस मिल जाती है
सर्वर एरर आ जाती है सर्वर अनरिस्पांसिव
वाली तो यहां पे आपका वो अटैक सक्सेसफुल
माना जाएगा आप उसको रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
ठीक
है हां हां डाल सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बट कुछ खास फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा उससे बट
या डाल सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है तो अब जो मैंने आपको आज व एबिलिटीज
बताई है बेसिकली ये सारी लेबिलिटी जो
मैंने आपको बताई है आज अ बेसिकली लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स के अंदर में ब्रोकन लिंक
हाईजैकिंग मिशिंग एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड ओरिजिन
आईपी डिस्क्लोजर हो गई आपकी सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग आफ्टर लॉग आउट एंड लॉन्ग
पासवर्ड डॉस अटैक अब ये जो लेबिलिटी ये
बहुत ही छोटी वले एबिलिटीज है बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट्स बहुत सारी प्रोग्राम्स इसको आउट
ऑफ स्कोप में रखती हैं यानी कि आप रिपोर्ट
करेंगे तो वो नॉट एप्लीकेबल या डुप्लीकेट
मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम या तो इनफॉर्मेटिव में
क्लोज हो जाता है बट बहुत सारी ऐसी
छोटी-मोटी प्रोग्राम्स हैं जो डायरेक्टली
आप
google2 50 $100 भी मिल जाते हैं तो आपको
वहां पे ट्राई आउट जरूर करना है इन
लेबिलिटी के लिए सिंपल सा फंड है ठीक है
दैट्ची एकदम से क्लियर हो गई होगी जो आज
मैंने आपको बताया आपके दिमाग में चला गया
होगा एंड आई होप कि आप इसकी प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे एंड जितनी प्रैक्टिस आप करेंगे
आपके लिए उतना बेटर होगा मैं तो इतना ही
बस बोलूंगा प्रैक्टिस मेक्स अ अ नीवन
परफेक्ट वही वाली चीज है यहां पे लिन पेज
को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा अगेन मैं आपको बार-बार
बोलता हूं एंड एक एथिकल हैकर बनना है आपको
तो आप हमारी इस कोर्स को इनरोल कर सकते
हैं हमारे डेनिक्स एडमी ए ऐप को इंस्टॉल
करके वहां से से भी आप इस कोर्स को डीसी
जीएसपी को इनरोल कर सकते हैं एंड यू कैन
बिकम एन एथिकल हैकर बिकॉज सब कुछ वहां कवर
किया गया है बग बाउटी वाली प्लेलिस्ट को
तो आप फॉलो कीजिए यहां पे बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट है यहां पे और अपकमिंग ट्रेनिंग जो
जो हैं आने वाली है वो आपको पता चल जाएंगी
बहुत जल्दी तो यू कैन जस्ट जॉइन दैट
ट्रेनिंग आल्सो सो बस आज के सेशन के लिए
आज की क्लास के लिए इतना ही थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशंस गाइ थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर कमिंग एंड कमिंग इन लाइव लाइव में ही
रहिए ज्यादा मजा आएगा और आप आने वाले टाइम
में अभी बहुत एक्साइटिंग चीजें एक्साइटिंग
वने एबिलिटीज बग जो हैं वो आने वाले हैं
आप सबके लिए अभी तो बहुत कुछ बचा है यार
अभी तो जो हमें पढ़ना है उसका 50 पर भी
कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ तो सोचो अभी कितना कुछ
बचा हुआ है तो आती रहेंगी आपके लिए
क्लासेस आती रहेंगी बस आप प्यार सपोर्ट
दिखाते रहिए अपनी एनर्जी को मेंटेन करके
रखिए इनकरेज्ड रहिए हमेशा मोटिवेटेड रहिए
जितना आप मोटिवेटेड रहेंगे उतना मैं भी
मोटिवेटेड रहूंगा सिंपल सा फंडा है ठीक है
तो और अपने दोस्तों के बीच सॉरी अपने जो
भी दोस्त यार जो भी हैं जिनके इंटरेस्ट है
इस फील्ड में तो आप उनके साथ शेयर कर सकते
हो और मैंने देखा पाकिस्तान के भी बहुत
सारे स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो इस बग बाउंट
ट्रेनिंग को करते हैं बग बाउंट कोर्स को
ये लाइव ट्रेनिंग को वो फॉलो अप कर रहे
हैं क्योंकि वो लिन पे रेगुलर पोस्ट करते
हैं मैं देखता हूं तो ट्स अ वेरी ग्रेट
थिंग मुझे काफी अच्छा लगता है कि अगर
सीखने को मिलता है तो चाहे वो इंडिया के
हो इंडिया से बाहर के हो देश के किसी भी
कोने से हो या देश के बाहर किसी भी कोने
से हो कहीं से भी हो डजन मैटर सीखने वाली
चीज है कहीं से भी कोई भी सीख सकता है बट
उसका गलत इस्तेमाल बस मत कीजिएगा बस इतना
ही रिक्वेस्ट है आपसे ट्स इट ठीक
है चलिए तो आज के लिए बस इतना ही गाइस एंड
हां एक
whatsapp2 मेंबर शायद अभी तो लिमिट क्रॉस
जब हो जाएगी तो दूसरा ग्रुप का लिंक वहां
आ जाएगा तो एक ग्रुप बनेगा जहां पर आप
डिस्कशन कर सकते हैं एक दूसरे से बात कर
सकते हैं एक दूसरे के नॉलेज को शेयर कर
सकते हैं एक दूसरे की हेल्प कर सकते हैं
बग बाउटी में एंड मैं चाहता हूं कि एक
बहुत बड़ा कम्युनिटी जाए बग बाउंटीज सरे
की हेल्प करते-करते आप बाउंटीज लेना शुरू
करें अपनी अचीवमेंट्स वहां पोस्ट करें
क्या बग मिला क्या बाउंटीज पे डाले एंड
ताकि मैं भी उसको दूसरो जगह दूसरे जगह
दिखा पाऊं हर जगह पोस्ट कर पाऊं कि भाई
चलो ये मेरे स्टूडेंट्स हैं इन्होंने फ्री
वाली कोर्स ट्रेनिंग ली और इतना कुछ कर पा
रहे हैं सो
दैट्ची सो मच एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव
सेशन में